You know, Will, I'd love to do a podcast with you today, but I'm a little sore about something. You know, I've noticed in the past, you know, you do like a fake countdown for stuff. And you will stop after three and you won't go all the way. We've been through this before. We did it on a previous cold open. I don't think I've ever mentioned this to you before. Five. It may have come up on a cold open once.
威尔，你知道吗，我今天很想和你一起录播客，但我对某件事有点不爽。你知道，我过去注意到，你总是喜欢搞那种虚假的倒计时。数到三就停了，不数到底。我们之前经历过这个。我们在之前的开场白里就这么干过。我想我以前从没跟你提过这个。五。它可能在某次开场白里出现过一次。
Welcome to Smartless. Now I'm, no, I'm going silent from four down. Welcome to Smart. How did everybody sleep? We just saw each other 10 hours ago. Really well. Good. Oh, good.
欢迎来到Smartless。现在我，不，我从四开始保持沉默。欢迎来到Smart。大家睡得怎么样？我们10小时前才见过面。非常好。不错。哦，太好了。
Why? Do you have a story about your sleep? No, I was good. It was okay. It was okay. No, but I... Wait, wait, did you have the mask on last night? No, I don't sleep with a mask.
为什么？你有关于睡眠的故事吗？不，我睡得很好。还可以。还可以。不，但我……等等，等等，你昨晚戴面罩了吗？不，我不戴面罩睡觉。
Oh, you don't do the hose and the... No, I stopped that. It didn't really work. Don't cover your mouth when you sneeze. No, I... By myself. I know. Just practice.
哦，你不用软管和……不，我停用了。那没多大用。打喷嚏时别捂嘴。不，我……我自己。我知道。练练就好。
No, because then I just get myself. Oh, because you're going to be on camera. It gets all over the Lorapiana. A beautiful, beautiful Casual. Beautiful Corpiana. Your friends of Lorapiana sent me this beautiful jacket. I like them, actually. I, uh, or him or whatever.
不，因为那样我会弄到自己身上。哦，因为你要上镜。会弄得到处都是，弄到Loro Piana上。一件漂亮、漂亮、休闲的。漂亮的Loro Piana。Loro Piana的朋友送了我这件漂亮的夹克。其实我挺喜欢他们的。我，呃，或者他，随便吧。
Do you? I, um, I did take a valiant to sleep like a cup. Look at him go. I don't know. He was sneezing. Will, did you get into the bottom of a bag last night? Are you all out? You have somebody on their way over?
你喜欢吗？我，嗯，我确实吃了一片安定来睡觉，像个杯子。看他那样子。我不知道。他在打喷嚏。威尔，你昨晚是不是把袋子底都掏空了？都吃完了？你让人送过来了吗？
It's, I don't even know. It must be the AC in this room or the something. Is it the AC? Is it the AC? No. We got a whole junk What was the last time you guys saw Dawn in New York City? I tell you, it's amazing.
我甚至不知道。肯定是这房间里的空调或者什么东西。是空调吗？是空调吗？不。我们有一大堆……你们上次在纽约市见到Dawn是什么时候？我告诉你，太棒了。
It's just so full of promise this year. John and his van? Yeah. I love going out for beers for breakfast. Oh, my God. Sean, what did you do last night? Scotty and I... Oh, I ran the show.
今年真是充满希望。约翰和他的货车？是啊。我喜欢早餐时出去喝啤酒。天哪。肖恩，你昨晚干什么了？斯科蒂和我……哦，我负责演出。
I have to run the line, so that took a couple hours. And then he did about a pound and a half of sloppy Joe's. By the way, I totally had a sloppy Joe. Higher. At 10 o'clock. That's crazy you just said that. It's not much of a stretch or a leap for me to go to. I really did have a sloppy job.
我得去跑流程，花了好几个小时。然后他吃了一磅半的Sloppy Joe（肉酱三明治）。顺便说一句，我确实吃了Sloppy Joe。更高。在10点钟。你刚才说这个真是太疯狂了。对我来说，这并不算太离谱。我确实吃了Sloppy Joe。
Did you put it together yourself or was it left over from the kitchen help you have? It was left over. But it's funny that you say that because I remember yesterday when I was like I'm eating lunch at 2.30, 2 o'clock or 2.30. So that's why I had a sloppy Joe at 10 o'clock. But then what did you have at your 2.30 late lunch? I had a fried chicken salad. You had a chicken salad? No, no, fried chicken salad.
是你自己做的，还是你家里的帮厨剩下的？是剩下的。但你说这个很有趣，因为我记得昨天我在想，我下午2点半或2点吃午饭。所以这就是为什么我在10点钟吃了Sloppy Joe。那你2点半的晚午餐吃了什么？我吃了炸鸡沙拉。你吃了鸡肉沙拉？不，不，炸鸡沙拉。
Oh, fried chicken salad. So they took what? They took the lettuce and the chicken. They threw it all in the friar? What happened? Everything gets fried in that scenario, even the bowl or... And then... How we call it tempura.
哦，炸鸡沙拉。所以他们怎么做的？他们把生菜和鸡肉拿去炸了？发生了什么？那种情况下什么都炸，连碗也……然后……我们管这叫天妇罗。
So you had the fried chicken salad. Tempora salad. Right, Sean? You had this snickerdoodle at 1130. Yeah, right? the big one. You kept going in and out of the bag to keep it fresh with your logic.
所以你吃了炸鸡沙拉。天妇罗沙拉。对吧，肖恩？你在11点半吃了那个士力架饼干。是啊，对吧？那个大的。你为了保持新鲜感，不断地把手伸进袋子里，这是你的逻辑。
That's exactly right. And the fried chicken at 2.30. So then at 2.30 you have the fried chicken salad with what did you drink. What was your beverage at that lunch? Milk with every meal. At the lunch? Yeah.
完全正确。然后2点半吃了炸鸡。所以2点半你吃了炸鸡沙拉，喝了什么？你午餐喝了什么饮料？每顿饭都喝牛奶。午餐也喝？是啊。
At the restaurant. No, no. Did they look at you? Did they say, did they say, is there a child coming to this lunch? No? It was here at home. We don't offer stuff.
在餐厅里？不，不。他们看着你了吗？他们有没有说，有没有说，是有个孩子要来吃午餐吗？没有？是在家里。我们不提供那些。
We don't have a kids menu. Yeah, but here are the crayons. But you have that at 2.30. And then you're, You're trying to tell us, you're trying to tell us that you have the fried chicken lunch, fried chicken salad, and that nothing, you had nothing else until you had the sloppy jump. At 1030. Yeah, that's true. No dinner.
我们没有儿童菜单。是啊，但这里有蜡笔。但你在2点半吃了那个。然后你，你试图告诉我们，你试图告诉我们你吃了炸鸡午餐，炸鸡沙拉，然后什么都没有，直到你吃了Sloppy Joe。在10点半。是啊，是真的。没吃晚饭。
Nothing. Nothing. No snack. No, no, no candy. You didn't graze, go by the candy jar? The candy bowl. I don't think I did. I don't think I did is a real soft way.
什么都没吃。什么都没吃。没吃零食。不，不，不吃糖果。你没去吃点零食，没去糖果罐那儿？糖果碗。我想我没吃。我想我没吃，这话说得真够委婉的。
It's an entry into, you know, actually, what was? it. Just be honest. Just a milky way. I maybe had a couple of starbursts. A couple of starbursts. There we go. So you wanted to get some plastic in there.
这是一种切入点，你知道，实际上，是什么？诚实点。就一个银河巧克力棒。我可能吃了几个星爆糖。几个星爆糖。这就对了。所以你想往里加点塑料。
He needs some binding. Something to bind up that sloppy Joe. Yeah, forget about rice. Wow. Oh, man. Anyway, anyway, what? And you're like, I can't, I can't figure it out. I don't find it.
他需要点粘合剂。能把那个Sloppy Joe粘住的东西。是啊，别提米饭了。哇。哦，天哪。不管怎样，不管怎样，什么？然后你说，我不能，我搞不清楚。我找不到原因。
I'm so tired all that. I don't know. My sleep's fucked up. It's so weird. No, no. What'd you have? Let me run you through it. None of it adds up.
我太累了，所有这些。我不知道。我的睡眠搞砸了。太奇怪了。不，不。你吃了什么？让我帮你梳理一下。这根本说不通。
Let me run you through it. I'll tell you what, though, Sean, I tell you what does that up. Oh, yeah. The acclaim for our guest. He has been nominated for four Golden Globes. Is that right? And he's won one. Oh, okay.
让我帮你梳理一下。不过，肖恩，我告诉你什么说得通。哦，是的。对我们嘉宾的赞誉。他曾四次获得金球奖提名。是这样吗？他赢了一次。哦，好的。
And he's been nominated for countless SAG Awards. I think like seven, won a couple of those. She won an Emmy nominated five times. Bafda's been nominated like seven, eight times, one two of those. This is the volified guest. This is a very qualified guess. This is a guy who his list of performances, is one of those guys that has its own page,
他还获得了无数次演员工会奖提名。我想大概七次，赢了两次。她赢过艾美奖，被提名五次。英国电影学院奖被提名了七八次，赢了两次。这是一位非常有资格的嘉宾。这是一位非常有资格的嘉宾。这家伙的表演列表，是那种拥有自己独立页面的家伙，
and has nothing to do with the length of time he's been on this planet, but just about the amount that people want him to be in their projects. I love that. I love him from everything. He is... It's one of the guys you're going to say, we'll guess it if we... You're going to guess if I say, he is the original Dr. Hannibal Lecter.
这与他在这个星球上待的时间长短无关，而仅仅是因为人们有多想让他出现在他们的项目中。我喜欢这个。我喜欢他的一切。他……他是那种你会说，如果我们猜的话……如果你说，他是最初的汉尼拔·莱克特博士，你就能猜到。
He's got a brave heart. He knows a little bit about the... Brian Cox. And he's also in line for succession. It is the one and only, Mr. Brian Cox. No way. Good Lord. This is a guest.
他有一颗勇敢的心。他了解一点……布莱恩·考克斯。他还在《继承之战》里。他就是那位独一无二的布莱恩·考克斯先生。不会吧。天哪。这位嘉宾。
Hello, sir. Good morning. Hello, Jason. Hello, Sean. Well done, Will. Nice to see you all. Yeah, great to see you. Plus, I should mention also, Brian, that your new film that you've directed,
你好，先生。早上好。你好，杰森。你好，肖恩。干得好，威尔。很高兴见到你们。是啊，很高兴见到你。另外，我应该提一下，布莱恩，你执导的新电影，
Glenn Rothen releases on April 17th. What's the name of it again? Glenn Rothen? It's called Glenn Rothen. It's about a... It's about a Scottish, it's about two brothers who are, they own this distillery. But one, the younger brother, who's played by, brilliantly, by Alan Cumming, he's the one that was the real talent in the family. And I also play Sandy, the oldest brother, who is just a plodder.
《Glenn Rothen》将于4月17日上映。名字叫什么来着？Glenn Rothen？它叫《Glenn Rothen》。它是关于一个……它是关于一个苏格兰的……关于两个兄弟，他们拥有一家酿酒厂。但其中一个，弟弟，由艾伦·卡明精彩地扮演，他是家里真正的天才。我也扮演桑迪，那个哥哥，他只是个苦干的人。
You know, he's just a manager, that's what he does. And the other brother has had a bad relationship with our father. I actually cast my own son as my father because I wanted him to see what it was like being a father. Oh, that's wild. That's wild. So we did that. And he was very good.
你知道，他只是个经理，这就是他做的。另一个兄弟和我们父亲的关系不好。我实际上选了我自己的儿子来演我的父亲，因为我想让他看看当父亲是什么感觉。哦，太疯狂了。太疯狂了。所以我们做了。他演得非常好。
He was very tough and very scary as well. Brian, this can't be the first time you've directed something, is it? No, I directed in the theater, but this was my debut as a film director. Wow. How did it go? What were you surprised with? I was surprised that I made it.
他演得很强硬，也很吓人。布莱恩，这不可能是你第一次执导电影吧？不，我在剧院执导过，但这是我作为电影导演的处女作。哇。进展如何？你有什么惊讶的吗？我惊讶的是我竟然完成了。
I don't mean I made the film. that I made it through the whole shoot. It was a bit scary. And it was a very odd situation to be in, you know, because I came from an egalitarian viewpoint. I wanted everybody to do their best work. You know, we've all suffered at the hands of various directors over the years and their conceptions that they wanted to include us.
我不是说我拍完了电影。我是说我熬过了整个拍摄过程。这有点吓人。而且处境非常奇怪，你知道，因为我来自一种平等主义的观点。我希望每个人都能做出他们最好的工作。你知道，多年来我们都受过各种导演的折磨，他们想把自己的构想强加给我们。
And I just want them to fuck off, really, basically. You know, fuck me about with all that shit that you're in all your ego stuff. control. And I just, I really, I'm, I, some directors I really like, I've worked with some really good ones. Yeah. But a lot of the time you go, the best director I've ever, I ever work with, unquestionably on film was Lindsay Anderson.
我真的只想让他们滚蛋，基本上。你知道，别用那些自我意识的东西来折磨我。控制欲。我真的，我，有些导演我真的很喜欢，我和一些非常好的导演合作过。是的。但很多时候你会说，我合作过的最好的电影导演，毫无疑问是林赛·安德森。
You know, the director, Lindsay Anderson? I don't. No. No, no. I should get to know it. God almighty, it's just appalling, you young people, what you don't know. Click, and then you just hang up. You live in a wonder world.
你知道那个导演林赛·安德森吗？我不知道。不。不，不。我应该了解一下。天哪，你们这些年轻人真是太糟糕了，什么都不知道。点击一下，然后就挂断了。你们生活在一个奇妙的世界里。
I don't know. Man or woman? A man, Lindsay's a man. He directed a very famous, well, he directed a series of films. The first film I ever saw was a thing called This Sporting Life. Oh, sure, I heard of that. With Richard Harris. Okay.
我不知道。男的还是女的？男的，林赛是个男的。他执导了一部非常著名的，嗯，他执导了一系列电影。我看到的第一部电影叫《如此运动生涯》。哦，当然，我听说过。理查德·哈里斯主演的。好的。
It's about a rugby team set up north, written by wonderful David Story, who's a great, well, he's passed away, a great writer. And, yeah, I mean, he was just... What made him great? What did you like about his style? Because he just gave you the right note. He gave you the right note. I mean, he would come up with Stey, we would do his scene,
那是关于一支在北方建立的橄榄球队，由伟大的大卫·斯托里编写，他已经去世了，一位伟大的作家。而且，是的，我的意思是，他只是……是什么让他变得伟大？你喜欢他的什么风格？因为他总是给你正确的指导。他给你正确的指导。我的意思是，他会走过来，我们会演他的场景，
and the play I did was with Alan Bates. Do you remember Alan Bates? To have a good name. Alan Bates, the actor Alan Bates. Yep. Sure. Sean, you know who the actor of Alan Bates. Yes, my God, you guys need some training.
我演的那部戏是和艾伦·贝茨一起的。你记得艾伦·贝茨吗？有个好名字。艾伦·贝茨，演员艾伦·贝茨。是的。当然。肖恩，你知道演员艾伦·贝茨是谁。是的，天哪，你们这些家伙需要一些培训。
You really do. Anyway, Alan Bates, who was famous in Zorba, the Greek, and he did a lot of movies, Alan. and he played my elder brother and I played the younger brother and Lindsay would come up with he said he would come and and we'd go it's good, it's good
真的需要。不管怎样，艾伦·贝茨，他在《希腊人佐巴》中很有名，他演过很多电影，艾伦。他演我的哥哥，我演弟弟，林赛会走过来，他说，他会过来，我们会说，这很好，这很好，
but there's a little bit of attitude andizing in the scenes can we kind of remove the attitude inizing and just play the scene? I mean that simple thing, the simple note where you go ah, I see what you mean I'm striking an attitude that I try to hold on
但场景里有一点做作，我们能不能去掉那种做作，只是演戏？我的意思是，那个简单的东西，那个简单的指导，让你觉得，啊，我明白你的意思了，我在摆姿势，我试图在整个场景中保持这种姿势，但实际上场景本身会展现出来，姿势也会展现出来，他是第一个理解这一点的导演。现在，大多数导演根本不知道他在说什么。对，对。
to throughout the scene but actually the scene reveals itself and the attitude reveals itself and he was the first director to understand. Now, most directors wouldn't know what the fuck he was talking about. Right, right.
你知道，他们根本一点头绪都没有，你知道。抱歉，我不能说太多。你知道林赛以前演过戏吗？不，他和一个叫加文·兰伯特的人创办了一本杂志叫《视与听》，那是战后真正的大型电影杂志，
You know, they just don't have a fucking clue, you know. Sorry, I mustn't be too much. Had Lindsay ever done any acting, do you know? No, he started a magazine with a guy called Gavin Lambert called Sight and Sound, which was the big first film magazine
因为他是个战争，你知道，他战后在大学。是的。他真是太不寻常了。我的意思是，他做的另一件事是一部叫《如果……》的电影。我不知道你们有没有看过。
that was made really after the war because he was a war, you know, he was at university post-war. Yeah. And he was just extraordinary. I mean, the other thing he did was a film called If. I don't know if you saw that.
那是马尔科姆·麦克道威尔主演的电影，背景是一所公立学校。那是一所公立学校。然后他拍了一部叫《幸运的人》的电影，那是那部电影的续集。所以赶快去买吧。是啊，是啊。我知道。
That was a film with Malcolm McDowell, which is set in a public school boy. It was a public school. And then he did a film called Oh Lucky Man, which was the follow-up to that. So catch-up buys. Yeah, yeah. I know.
我知道。我觉得我好像看过《如果……》。等等，布莱恩。你在想瑞安·雷诺兹的那个垃圾，那个瑞辛斯基的载体。我正要说这个。你是对的，也许是个想象中的朋友。那很有趣。
I know. I feel like I've seen If. Wait, Brian. You're thinking of the Ryan Reynolds' junk, Rizinski vehicle. I was just going to say that. You're right, maybe an imaginary friend. That was a lot of fun.
那真的很有趣。布莱恩，当你最终完成你的长片导演处女作时，你有没有发现它改变了，你有没有回过头来改变你对导演的看法，它有没有平衡一些事情？嗯，我更同情他们了，但我仍然认为他们中的一些人是混蛋。是的，当然。抱歉，抱歉，我必须太……这很棒。
That was a lot of fun. Brian, did you have, so when you ended up making your feature film debut, directorial debut, did you find that it shifted, did you sort of retroactively, like go back and kind of shift your opinion of directors and did it sort of even anything out? Well, I had more sympathy for them, but I still think a bunch of them are twats. Yeah, sure. I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I must be too. It's great.
但我认为你们都会同意我的观点。我想你们也都经历过，你知道，那些家伙。是的，这总是很有趣。你知道，导演肯定需要有一个计划，请原谅这个词，一个愿景之类的东西。但当谈到表演时，你意识到他们认为他们可以控制它，但这是制作过程中少数几个你无法控制的环节之一。你无法控制表演。
But I think you all agree with me. I think you've all been through that as well, you know, those guys. Yeah, it's always interesting. You know, a director definitely needs to have a plan and pardon the term, a vision and all that stuff. But when it comes to performance, you realize that they think they can control it, but it is like one of the few lanes in making something that you can't control. You can't control performance.
你无法控制音乐。就像，其他所有东西你都可以介入并做出决定。但表演和音乐，在“开始”和“停”之间发生的事情是你无法微观管理的。它必须活着，它必须呼吸。那个角色是演员的角色。它不是导演的角色，也不是编剧的角色。
You can't control music. Like, everything. else you can kind of get in there and make a decision on. But performance and music, there's stuff that happens in between action and cut that you just can't micromanage. It's got to live, it's got to breathe. And that character is the actor's character. It's not the director's character or the writer's correct character.
就像，你必须拥有它。能够给演员那种真正感觉它是他们自己的自由度，我认为这会释放出一种非常令人兴奋的表演，而不是试图让他们做你脑海中一直看到的那个版本。对。绝对。绝对。嗯，你知道，过去50年甚至60年我一直受此折磨。
Like, you have to own it. And to be able to give the actor the kind of latitude to really feel like it's theirs, I think that frees up a really exciting performance as opposed to trying to get them to do the version of the character you always saw in your head. Right. Absolutely. Absolutely. Well, you know, I've suffered under that for the last 50 years or even 60 years.
嗯，你非常非常成功地克服了它。天哪，我能看到的你的表演，布莱恩。这只是，谢谢。让我说声谢谢。是的，你做过太多了。而且，你知道，这些家伙知道我一直在谈论我最喜欢的一些电影。你也有威尔最喜欢的名言之一。关于什么来着，我在这里转述一下，嗯，我太老了，太有钱了，太出名了，不在乎了。
Well, you've pushed through it very, very successfully. My God, the performances I've been able to watch you do, Brian. It's just, thank you. Let me just say thank you. Yeah, you have done so many. And, you know, these guys know I've gone on and on about some of my favorite films. And you have one of one of Will's favorite quotes, too. about what is it i'm going to paraphrase it here um i'm too old too rich and too famous to give a fuck
是的，差不多就是这样，我太老了，太累了，太有才华了，不在乎了。太棒了，对吧？我太喜欢了，我他妈的太喜欢了。我喜欢你那种，以最好的方式，你不在乎，但我知道你在乎你在乎的事情。只是那些愚蠢的事情。完全正确。完全正确。嗯，我决心用这部电影做的是让每个人都发挥他们的才华。你知道，服装部门，衣橱部门，我的意思是，那是一样的。
yeah it's something like that i'm too old too tired and too talented to give a fuck it's so good right i love that so fucking much i just fucking love it i love how you don't and i'm in the best way you don't give a shit uh but i know you do about the things you do give a shit about Just the silly stuff. Exactly. Exactly. Well, the thing I was determined to do with the movie was to get everybody give their talent. You know, the costume department, the wardrobe department, the, I mean, that's the same.
还有电影的设计和摄影指导。而且，你知道，你只是想让人们做出他们最好的工作，而不是说，按这个方式做。对。因为一旦你说，按这个方式做，你就立刻给他们设置了一个障碍，让他们觉得，哦，我必须按这个方式做。我做不到。所以我没做任何那种事。我只是说，给我你所能给我的。告诉我你想让我做什么。
And the design of the film and the DP. And, you know, you just want people to do their best work, not to say, do it this way. Right. Because once you say, do it this way, you've immediately put a block up for them to go, oh, I've got to do it this way. I can't do it. So I didn't do any of that. I just said, give me what you're giving me. Tell me what you want me to do.
告诉我你想做什么。在设计部门，告诉我你想实现什么。因此，我们有一个非常快乐的剧组。这可能是一部糟糕的电影，但我们有一个快乐的剧组。不，但这是一种真正的合作。我的意思是，你雇佣那些人是有原因的，因为你喜欢他们所做的事情。你提供了一个环境，让他们觉得他们可以。完全正确，威尔。
Tell me what you want to. In the design department, tell me what you want to achieve. And therefore, one had an incredibly happy crew. It's probably a terrible film, but we had a happy crew. No, but it's a true collaboration. I mean, you hired those people for a reason because you like what they do. You provide an environment where they feel like they can. That's exactly right, Will.
完全正确。而且这种情况发生得还不够多。我们不信任。我们真的不信任。我们信任得还不够。如果有人走过来说，这是设计，你只是说，好吧，让我们看看你做什么。
That's exactly right. And not enough of that goes on. We don't trust. We really don't trust. We don't trust nearly enough. And if somebody comes on and says, this is the design, you just say, well, let's see what you do.
做你想做的事。做你觉得正确的事。当然，你可以修改之类的。但至少你没有阻碍他们。你没有阻止他们发挥创造力。是的。等等，那么对于《Glenn Rothen》，是你找到了这个项目，还是项目找到了你？
And do what you want to do. Do what you feel is right. And of course, you can modify and all that. But at least you're not impending them. You're not stopping them from being creative. Yeah. Wait, so for Glenn Roth, and is it, did you find the project or did the project find you?
那是怎么发生的？嗯，这是一个，这是一个，我没有找到这个项目。它是由一个叫大卫·阿什顿的人写的。我，你知道，我们仍然在做广播，你相信吗，我不知道，你知道什么是广播吗？当然，当然。是啊，当然。不管怎样，我们仍然，我仍然在老家做广播。我已经做了一个系列20年了，我会去录三天。这是一个关于爱丁堡侦探麦克莱维的系列。它非常受欢迎。我们有大约一百万听众。哇。大卫写了这个。他们来找我，一个叫尼尔·齐格的人，他也是个朋友。
How did that happen? Well, it was a, it was, I didn't find the project. It's written by a guy called, David Ashton. I do, you know, we still do radio back, would you believe, I don't, you know what the radio is? Sure, sure. Yeah, sure. Anyway, we still, I still do radio back in the old country. And I've been doing a series for 20 years, which I'd go off and do for three days. And it's a series about an Edinburgh detective called McClevee. And it's been very popular. We get about a million listeners. Wow. And David wrote this. And they came to me, a guy called Neil Ziger, who's also a pal.
尼尔说，你要执导这部电影。我从来没执导过电影。我说，什么？他说，你要执导这部电影。他们说，而且你可以参演。我说，哦，那太好了。谢谢你让我参演。你可以自己选角。
And Neil said, you're going to be directing this film. And I've never directed a film. And I said, what? He said, you're going to direct the film. And they said, and you could be in it. I said, oh, that's kind. And thank you for letting me be in it. You can cast yourself.
是的。嗯，你知道，你知道，这是一个美妙的，美妙的。苏格兰有一位伟大的喜剧演员叫斯坦利·巴克斯特，他过去常演一个场景，他演一个小男孩。还有他的祖父快要去世了，他的祖父看着窗外说，孩子，有一天，这一切都会是你的，从山丘到河流，还有外面所有的土地。
Yeah. Well, you know, you know, it's a wonderful, wonderful. There's a great comedian in Scotland called Stanley Baxter, and there's a great scene which he used to do when he played a little boy. And also his grandfather's dying, and his grandfather's looking at the window and saying, son, one day, all this will be yours, from the hills to the river and all that land out there.
他没完没了地说。那个小男孩说，你知道，爷爷，对于一个孤身一人的小男孩来说，那可是个太大的工作了。所以这就是我被提醒的，对于一个孤身一人的小男孩来说，这是一个多么大的工作。嗯，很有趣，很有趣你提到那个孤身一人的小男孩，因为我在想你，你在邓迪长大，苏格兰，在邓迪出生长大。
And he goes on and on and on. And the wee boy says, you know, grandpa, that's an awfully big job for one wee boy in his own. So that's what I was reminded of How an awfully big job it is for one wee boy on his own Well, it's funny it's funny you mention that one wee boy on his own Because I was thinking about you're you grew up in Dundee Scott Born and raised in Dundee Scalling
是的。现在你是一个，原谅我，一个世界著名的演员，备受赞誉的演员，你是怎么从那个变成那个的？从我读到的非常非常卑微的出身到那个，那次飞跃是什么？哦，是的。嗯，我父亲在我那个年纪去世了。我妈妈有一个，他才51岁，他得了胰腺癌，我八岁时他就去世了。
Yeah And and now you're a sort of Forgive me as sort of a world famous actor Reclaimed actor how did you go from that to that What was that leap from what I've read of very, very humble beginnings? Oh, yeah. Well, my dad died when I was age. And my mom had a, he was only 51, he had pancreatic cancer, and he died when I was eight.
我有三个姐姐。我是最小的，还有一个有点疯狂的哥哥，他总是消失。他比我大九岁。我是个婴儿。我父亲去世了。然后我妈妈经历了一系列可怕的神经崩溃，导致她接受了电休克治疗，我的意思是，她体重减轻了大约60磅。
And I had three elder sisters. I was the youngest and a kind of crazy brother who used to go off and disappear. And he was nine years older than me. And I was the baby. And my dad died. And then my mom had a series of terrible nervous breakdowns which resulted in her having electric shock treatment, which, I mean, she lost about 60 pounds in weight.
我的意思是，她都认不出来了。我的意思是，她开始时有点超重，但后来体重不足。所以我大部分时间都没有父母……我有我的姐姐们，我没意识到，但这发生在我身上是最好的事情。从某种意义上说，失去母亲和父亲是一场悲剧。
I mean, she was unrecognized. I mean, she was a little overweight to start with, but she was underweight. So I had no parents for most of my... I had my sisters, and I didn't realize it, but it was the best thing that ever happened to me. It's a tragedy, in one sense, losing your mom and losing your dad.
当然，这令人心碎。但我被解放了。没有混蛋告诉我该做什么。没有混蛋在，没有父母在给……你多大？你父亲去世时你八岁？然后你妈妈，你妈妈去世时你多大？嗯，她去世得晚得多，但我妈妈几乎
Certainly, it was heartbroken. But I was liberated. it. No fucker was telling me what to do. No fucker was getting, no parent was giving... How old did you? You were eight years old when your dad passed? And then your mom, and how old were you when your mom? Well, she died much later, but my mom went into almost
立刻就崩溃了。她经历了一次巨大的崩溃，她简直无可救药。而且，我们当时在送我最小的姐姐，实际上是我最大的姐姐中最小的，你知道，她比我大12岁。还有我的两个姐姐，她们结婚了，有孩子，我的意思是，我是，她们太棒了。她们所做的一切太棒了，但她们，她们没有照顾我，但她们照看我，这比被照顾要好。
immediately. She had a huge breakdown and she was just hopeless. And also, we were sending my youngest sister, actually my youngest of my oldest sisters, you know, she's 12 years older than me. And there were my two older sisters who were married, had children, I mean, I was, they were amazing. They were just amazing what they did, but they did, they didn't look after me, but they looked out for me, which was better than being looked after.
她们确保我没事。你发现你做了很多非常好的决定吗，还是你做了一些糟糕的决定并从中吸取了教训？嗯，你只是学习，你知道，你学习，你知道，我的意思是，我做了好的决定，也做了坏的决定，你知道，但我做了，但至少我能看清局势，你知道，发生了什么。但我能想象那时的邓迪，苏格兰，是一个很难成长的地方。是啊，是啊，不容易，你知道，而且现在更难了
They made sure that I was okay. Did you find that you were making a lot of really good decisions, or did you make some bad ones and learn from those? Well, you just learn, you know, you learn, you know, I mean, I made good decisions and I made bad decisions, you know, but I made, but at least I could get the lie of the land, you know, what was going on. But I imagine that Dundee's, Scotland, at that, time was a tough place to grow up yeah yeah it wasn't easy you know and uh it's a lot tougher now
因为我们有，你知道，别让我开始，但他们，我们有，嗯，抱歉，我想在这个问题上更幽默一点，但我的意思是，不，不，你完全融入了。不，发生了什么事是，在我自己的城镇，我们有欧洲最高的海洛因成瘾率。哦，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇。是的，是的，因为贫困，这一切都是关于贫困。这就是让我成为社会主义者的原因。社会主义者，我的意思是，我无法忍受这个国家，我们所在的这个国家，他们是如何把共产主义和社会主义混为一谈的。社会主义不是共产主义。
because we have the you know don't get me started but they we have um sorry i wanted to be more humorful on this but i mean no no it's you fitting right in no what what happened is that we have the highest heroin addiction in europe in my own town oh wow wow wow wow wow wow yeah yeah because of the poverty and it's all about poverty And it's what makes me a socialist. Socialists, I mean, what I can't stand about this country, we're in, is how they confuse communism with socialism. Socialism is not communism.
社会主义是社会福利，照顾人民。共产主义是一种独裁。所以，你知道，我希望美国人能理解这一点，区别是什么。祝你好运。什么是社会主义者。作为一个加拿大人，让我说，祝你试图向他们解释好运，布莱恩。嗯，他们在纽约弄明白了。
Socialism is social welfare, taking care of the people. Communism is a dictate. So, you know, and I wish Americans would understand that, what the difference is. Good luck. What a socialist is. As a Canadian, let me say, good luck to you trying to explain it to them, Brian. Well, they've figured it out in New York.
而且艾丁似乎理解得很好。是的。我们有相当好的理解。我不是不尊重杰森或肖恩，但是，你知道，美国人不明白。他们就是不明白。嗯，他们不理解。而且我不是，我不认为自己真的是什么，但我确实明白我们必须照顾。我们只有最弱的一环那么强，这个想法，我们只有最弱的一环那么强。
And Aiding seemed to understand it rather well. Yeah. We've got a pretty good understanding. I don't disrespect to either Jason or Sean, but, you know, Americans don't get it. They just don't get it. Well, they don't understand. And I'm not, I don't consider myself really anything, but I do understand that we have to take care. We're only as strong, the idea, we're only as strong as our weakest link.
而且必须有一个网，因为一旦你，如果没有一种社会保障网，那么整个事情就会分崩离析。它会从下面腐烂，如果你有极端的贫困，就像我们在这个国家所拥有的那样，那么整个事情都在休息，我们社会的基石从下面腐烂了，你知道？所以，不管怎样。
And that there has to be a net, because once you, if there is not a sort of a social net, then the whole thing falls apart. and it sort of decays from underneath, if you have extreme poverty, which we do in this country, then the entire thing is resting, the foundation of our society is rotted from underneath, you know? So, anyway.
所以，布莱恩，在那里长大，你说情况没那么糟，但什么给了你希望或勇气去寻求更好的东西？嗯，我有两位老师。我的意思是，我的教育是一场灾难。那是技术教育。我本应该是，
So, Brian, growing up there, you said it wasn't as bad, but what gave you the hope or the courage to seek something better? Well, I had two teachers. I mean, my education was a disaster. It was a technical education. I was supposed to be,
我被训练成泥瓦匠，真的，我被训练成。我的意思是，我这辈子从来没砌过一块砖，但要么，你知道，但那应该是我的命运。我想，去他妈的士兵游戏。我不做那个。我不做那个。
I was trained to be a bricklayer, really, I was trained to be. I mean, I never laid a brick in my life, but either, you know, but that's supposed to be my destiny. And I thought, fuck that for a game of soldiers. I'm not doing that. I'm not doing that.
我不是那种人。我只是想成为一名演员。我从三岁起就想成为一名演员，你知道，那就是我渴望去演戏。那来自哪里？你看很多电视吗？或者？哦，我，我家乡有21家电影院。哇。
I'm not very in that way. And I just wanted to be an actor. I wanted to be an actor since I was three, you know, and that was my desire just to act. Where did that come from? Did you watch a lot of TV or? Oh, I, we had 21 cinemas in my hometown. Wow.
哇。那真是太多了。战前，我们有42家电影院。但战后，我们有21家，现在大约有四家。我参观了每一家电影院。我住的地方，离我住的地方往上走，有直角。有一个叫达西石露台的地方。那里有我的教堂，图书馆，百老汇电影院，
Wow. That's a ton. Before the war, we had 42 cinemas. But after the world, we had 21, and now there's about four. And I visited every single cinema. And where I lived, there was right angles to where I lived up from up the street. There was a thing called Darcy's Stone Terrace. And there was my church, the library, the Broadway cinema,
对面是皇家电影院。那是双片连映。所以你6点进去，11点出来。所以我经常去那里。事实上，我很惊讶当他们还活着的时候，他们甚至注意到我的存在，我的父母，因为我大部分时间都在电影院里。这是一种逃避现实的形式吗？
and opposite that was the Royal. And it was double features. So you'd go in at 6 o'clock and you would get out 11. So I used to go there all the time. In fact, I'm surprised that when they were alive, that they even noticed I existed in my parents because I was in the cinema most of the time. Was it a form of escapism?
这就是最初把你带进剧院的原因吗？不，我不认为这是逃避现实。这只是快乐。是的，是的。我的意思是，我从中得到了太多的快乐，你知道。你住在邓迪，那在当时相当沉重，你知道。我的意思是，这是一个伟大的社区。我的意思是，那个观点，但城市之父，
Is that what brought you into the theater initially? No, I don't think it's escapism. It's just joy. Yeah, yeah. I mean, I just got so much joy out of it, you know. You live in Dundee, which was pretty heavy going, you know, in those days. I mean, it's a great community. I mean, that view, but the city father,
总是搞砸。你知道，他们把人们从城里带出来，把他们放进这些计划中，这就是为什么他们现在还在为此付出代价。事实上，市长对我说，你知道，我们正试图让人们回到城里。我说，你们当初就不应该把他们从城里带出来。
always make a ball's up. You know, they took people out of the town and they put them in these schemes, which is why they're still paying for it now. In fact, the Lord Provost said to me, you know, we're trying to get people back into the city. I said, you should never have taken them out the city in the first fucking place.
我说，那太重要了。这就是他们是谁。他们来自那里，然后你把他们，你孤立他们，没有任何适当的条件，你知道。因此，海洛因，醉汉，整个事情就失控了，你知道。这是让我越来越生气的事情。是的，是的，是的。
I said, that's so important. That's who they are. They're from that, and then you put them, you isolate them without any proper conditions, you know. And therefore, the heroin, the drunks, the whole thing just spirals out of, you know. this is something that really gets me more and more and more. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。所以你有这种对电影的热爱。你一直去剧院。然后你去了，如果我没记错的话，你去了苏格兰的戏剧学校。我去了兰达。哦，你去了兰达。好的。
We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. So then you have this love of cinema. You're going to the theater all the time. And then you went to, if I'm right, you went to theater school in Scotland. I went to Lambda. Oh, you went to Lambda. Okay.
是的，美妙的是我当时，有一个叫比尔·戴维斯的家伙，邓迪剧目剧院有一系列导演。最后一个人是一个叫比尔·戴维斯的加拿大人。现在，比尔在他自己心中是一位导演和作家。他住在温哥华。而且，他是那个戴维斯家族的一部分，你知道，那个在加拿大经营很多剧院的著名戴维斯家族。比尔很棒。他说，他邀请了我。我想我当时才16岁，如果那是的话，不管怎样。是的，我才16岁。他邀请我去参加一个声音课。我从来没上过声音课。我甚至不知道声音课是什么。什么是声音课？他说，来参加声音课。我去了，那里有这个，他说，我们有这个从伦敦来的年轻女士，她刚刚接手，
Yeah, what was wonderful was I was, there was a guy called Bill Davis, there was a series of directors at Dundee Rep. And the last guy was a Canadian called Bill Dave. Now, Bill is a director and a writer in his own mind. He lives in Vancouver. And also, he's part of that Davis, you know, the famous Davis family who run a lot of theaters in Canada. And Bill was great. And he said, he invited me. I was, I think I was just 16, if that, anyway. Yeah, I was just 16. And he invited me to a voice class. And I'd never been to a voice class. I didn't even know what a voice class was. What's a voice class? He said, come along to voice class. and I went along and there was this he said we've got this young woman who's coming up from London she's just taken over now
因为之前那个天才声音老师去世了，这位女士接手了，我说，这是谁，她说她叫克里斯汀·林克莱特，你听说过克里斯汀·林克莱特吗？不，你看，所以我们什么都不知道，是的，我很惊讶怎么
because the previous voice teacher who was a genius died and this lady's taken on and I said who is this she says she's called Kristen Linklater have you heard of Kristen Linklater no you see so we don't know anything yeah I'm smart I'm surprised how
你们两个真的这么无知，除了那个加拿大人，我发现那个加拿大人一点也不无知，但你们两个家伙真的，你们说对了，你们说对了。你知道，你坐在那里想，哦。是的，是的，我们是来学习的。像个小婴儿。所以不管怎样，她是，去查查克里斯汀·林克莱特，因为她，她很遗憾地去世了。
really ignorant you both are except the Canadian I find the Canadian isn't ignorant at all but you two guys are really You're right on, you're right on the money, you're right on the money. You know, you sit there and wonder going, oh. Yeah, yeah, we're here to learn. Like a little baby boy. So anyway, she was, look up Kristen Laker because she was, she's sadly possible.
她的儿子是一个叫哈米什·林克莱特的演员。我不知道你们有没有遇到过他。而她，不，是的，不，你不知道。那泰勒·史密斯呢？哦，哇。不管怎样。他们认为你在编造这些名字。我知道，我知道。
Her son is an actor called Hamish Linklater. I don't know if you've come across him. And she, no, yeah, no, you don't know. What about like Taylor Smith? Oh, wow. Anyway. They think that you're making these names up. I know, I know.
哦，等等，是的。我知道哈米什·林克莱特。他们是引起共鸣的演员。抱歉？你们知道哈米什·林克莱特。我知道谁，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的。是的，是的，是的，是的，是的。天哪，那个加拿大人，他太理智了。
Oh, wait, yes. I know Hamish-Linclair. They're actors that resonate. Pardon? You guys know Hamish-Link later. I know who, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes. God, the Canadian, he's so sensible.
你们两个到底怎么了？我的谷歌更快，但我确切地知道哈米什·林克莱特是谁。所以不管怎样，所以发生了。所以我去了邓迪。我在邓迪的第一天是非常有趣的一天，因为我去面试，我走到剧院前面，这个女人用非常浓重的邓迪口音。
What is wrong with you two others? My Google's faster, but I know exactly who Hamish-link later. So anyway, so that happens. So I go to Dundee. My first day in Dundee was a very funny day because I went up for my interview and I went up to the front of the theatre and this woman in a very broad Dundonio.
我说，你要什么，孩子？我说，我来面试第一场。我说，你可以从前面进前面。你必须去后面才能到前面。你可以从前面进前面。所以去后面，然后你就能到前面。我说，好的，所以我绕到了后面。当我走进去时，有一场巨大的争吵，
I said, you want you, son? I said, I'm here for an interview first. I said, you can kind of get into the front for the front. You've got to go to the back to get to the front. You can get to the front for the front. So go to the back and then you can get to the front. I said, okay, so I went round the back. And as I walked in, there was an almighty row
一场争吵正在发生，在一个演员之间，现在，我要说一个演员的名字，你可能甚至不知道他他妈的是谁，但不管怎样，他非常出名。我们到目前为止还不错。你得分很高。不管怎样，这个演员叫尼科尔·威廉姆森。哦，是的。
a fight going on between an actor Now, I'm going to say an actor's name, and you probably don't even know who the fuck he is, but anyway, he was very well known. We've been pretty good so far. You've scored brilliantly. Anyway, this actor was called Nickel Williamson. Oh, yes.
尼科尔。如果我有一枚镍币。太棒了。我们终于挖到金子了。不管怎样，所以我，这个，尼科尔·威廉姆森，他不打算用他，我在赚钱。那是一个对他很棒的模仿。别这样。
Nichol. If I had a nickel. It's great. We've struck gold at last. Anyway, so I'm, this, Nicol Williams, and he's not going to use him, I'm making money. And that is a great impression of him. Stop it.
你，你，让他。我正试图绕过他们去面试。我15岁，我以前从来没去过后台。所以我爬上去，我正爬上楼梯。我终于绕过了他们。我站在平台上，有一个很棒的演员冈恩·格兰杰在抽烟。他看着我说，
You, you, make him. and I'm trying to get past them to get off of my interview. And I'm 15, and I've never been in a backstage before. So I'm getting up and I'm planning up the stairs. I get past them, finally. And I'm standing on the landing, and there's a wonderful article Gone Granger's smoking a cigarette. And he looked at me and he said,
你还好吗，亲爱的？我说，那个人刚才叫我亲爱的。对。我这辈子从来没被叫过亲爱的。这显然是我必须待的地方。我必须待在这个地方。对，那太棒了。嗯，我必须问你，因为我总是问这个问题的人，
Are you all right, darling? And I went, that man just called me darling. Right. I have never been called darling before in my life. This is clearly where I must be. I have to be in this place. Right, that's great. Well, I have to ask you, because I'm the person that always asked this,
你做过的最喜欢的舞台表演是什么，在剧院里发生过的最糟糕的事情是什么？嗯，发生过的最糟糕的事情，实际上我做过的最喜欢的表演之一是我做了一个，你知道康纳·麦克弗森是谁吗？不，你看。他是一位非常有名的爱尔兰剧作家，他在百老汇演过几部戏，
what's your favorite stage show you've ever done, and what's the worst thing that's ever happened on stage in the Love Theater? Well, the worst thing ever happened, and actually one of my favorite shows I did was I did a show by, do you know who Connor McPherson is? No, there you go. He's a very famous Irish playwright, and he's had a few plays on Broadway,
我演过他的一部戏叫《圣尼古拉斯》，我在里面演一个剧评人。那是一场独角戏。那是一场精彩的表演，真的非常非常有趣，非常有创意。它是关于这个剧评人变得对这个女演员着迷，他变得着迷，他跟踪她。他跟踪她。她演的戏，他在都柏林给了差评，
and I did a play of his called St. Nicholas, in which I played a theatre critic. It was a one-man show. It was a wonderful show, really very, very funny, very inventive. And it's about this theatre critic who becomes obsessed by this actress, and he becomes obsessed by, and he follows her. And he follows it. The play she's in, he gives a bad review to in Dublin
因为他可怕的评论，在和这个女演员调情后，他成了不受欢迎的人。最后他去了，他跟踪他们到伦敦，他跟踪他们到他们的家。他差点强奸了那个女孩，但他没有。所以他最终被赶了出来。他最终去为吸血鬼工作。他在水晶宫山上遇到了一个吸血鬼，
and his persona non-grata because of his terrible review, having flirted with this actress. And finally he goes, he follows them to London, and he follows them to their home. And he nearly rapes the girl, but he doesn't. So he ends up being kicked out. And he eventually goes to work for vampires. He meets a vampire on Crystal Palace Hill,
这个吸血鬼说，如果你能把人带到我们家，而且，你知道，我们喜欢吸血，但我们从不杀人。我们只是吸。我们不杀人。这看起来很合理。我说，这对我来说很合理。
and this vampire says, if you could bring people to our house, and, you know, we like to suck blood, but we never kill. We just only suck. We don't kill. It seems reasonable. And I said, that seems reasonable to me.
但想法是他会给我一个空间，这样我就可以写作。他整个点的，是他想要一些东西来写这个故事。所以我演了这场戏，这是一场非常好的戏。所以有一天晚上我上台，我开始演戏，我向右看，那是我的前女友。哦，天哪。我想，她在这里干什么？
But the idea was he would allow me a space so I could write. And the whole point of his, is the fact that he's wanting something to write this story. So I did this play, which was a really good play. So I one night had come on, and I start the play, and I look to my right, and there's my ex-girlfriend. Oh, my God. I think, what is she doing here?
然后我继续演，然后我转过身，在我的另一边是我的前前女友，她们真的坐在彼此对面。哦，是的。我完全被搞糊涂了。我只是对观众说，我说，对不起，女士们先生们，但我得重新开始。
And then I'd carry on, and then I turn over, and there on my other side was my ex-ex-girlfriend, and they're literally sitting opposite one another. Oh, yeah. And I'm completely thrown. And I just say to the audience, I said, I'm sorry, ladies and gentlemen, but I'm going to have to start again.
不会吧。是的。我说，我得重新开始，因为这是，我无法解释这是什么，但真的请相信我，第二次我会演得更好。那太……你在演出后见到她们了吗？
No way. Yeah. I said, I'm going to have to start again because this is, I can't explain what it is, but really just please trust me, I will be better second time. That is so. Did you see them after the show?
我见了。哦，天哪。我见了。发生的事情是演出结束后，她们走过来，她们说，哦，那太可爱了。我们很喜欢。哦，太棒了。
I did. Oh, my God. I did. What happened was after the show, they came on and they said, oh, that was lovely. We enjoyed it. Oh, and tremendous.
我说，你为什么坐在，对其中一个女孩说，你为什么坐在艾琳娜对面？她说，我没有。我说，你坐了。她说，嗯，我从来没注意到。我说，我注意到了什么？你坐在她对面，你真的坐在她正对面。我说，你知道吗，不，我从来没注意到。
And I said, why were you sitting, to one of the girls, I said, why were you sitting opposite Arena? And she said, I wasn't. I said, you were. She said, well, I'd never notice. I said, what I noticed? You were sitting opposite her, and you're literally sitting right opposite. And I said, do you know, no, I'd never notice.
我对其中一个女孩说，你为什么要坐着？我说，你为什么要坐在Arena对面？她说，我没有。我说，你明明坐着。她说，好吧，我从来没注意到。我说，我注意到了什么？你当时就坐在她对面，而且是正对着她坐。我说，你知道吗，不，我从来没注意到。
And so I went through agony for no reason. And they have no sense. Yeah. And that was it. But that's the, Sean, it makes me think, Sean, you're about to do a one-man show. Oh, right. Sean is, Sean opens what it'll be on now,
所以我无缘无故地经历了痛苦。他们根本没脑子。是啊。就是这样。但肖恩，这让我想到，肖恩，你马上要演独角戏了。哦，对。肖恩是，肖恩开演的时候，现在应该已经，
I think, uh, by the time this air is. But Sean's doing a one-man show off Broadway. What's it called, Shawnee and what theater will it be in? It's called the, thanks you guys.
我想，呃，等这期节目播出的时候。但肖恩正在外百老汇演独角戏。叫什么名字，肖尼，会在哪个剧院演？叫《谢谢你们》。
It's called the unknown and it's at Studio C-view, which is, um, 43rd and 8th Avenue. It's a, yeah, it's, but Brian, you'll understand,
叫《未知》，在C-view工作室，呃，第43街和第八大道。是，是，但布莱恩，你会理解的，
having to explain like doing a one-man show. And I was talking to Sean as he's been preparing for it this fall. And just getting off book. Yeah. Just learning. the fucking, the weight of... It's another story. I'm still not off book totally, and it's been three months.
不得不解释演独角戏是什么感觉。我跟肖恩聊过他今年秋天为演出做的准备。刚脱稿。是啊。刚开始学。该死的，那种压力……那是另一个故事了。我到现在还没完全脱稿，已经三个月了。
You're pretty good. Yeah, decent, yeah. He runs the show every day. You have to, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I mean, I'm scared shitless. I mean, we're recording this, and I haven't opened yet by the time this comes out, I haven't opened.
你已经很不错了。是啊，还行，是啊。他每天都在排练。你必须得这样，对吧？是啊，是啊，是啊。我是说，我吓得要死。我是说，我们在录这期节目，等它播出时我还没首演，我还没开演呢。
So if I, if I'm alive, I'll let you know. But isn't it? Send the post God. Yeah, but Brian, I mean, like the one-man show thing, it's just, it's colossal, isn't it? Yeah, it is. It is. I mean, I remember I came on one night
所以如果我，如果我还活着，我会告诉你们的。但不是吗？寄张明信片吧。是啊，但布莱恩，我是说，独角戏这事儿，简直太庞大了，不是吗？是啊，确实。确实。我是说，我记得有天晚上我上台，
and a guy, I walked on and a guy, he said, I came on he opened his program and he went, and I took the program out of his hand. Through it? I walked past him. I just took the program out of his own. But isn't it, I mean, did you ever go off,
有个家伙，我走上台，有个家伙，他说，我上台时他打开节目单，然后他发出声音，我直接从他手里把节目单拿走了。扔了？我从他身边走过。我直接从他手里拿走了节目单。但不是吗，我是说，你有没有过，
like go up on the line? I said in rehearsal, I was like, can I please have the script just off stage for emergencies if I can't remember where I'm at, I just have to, I'm just going to, there's nothing you can do. You just got to walk off. So you're just going to dip off stage and take a look?
比如忘词了？我在排练时说，能不能请把剧本放在台下，以防万一我记不住自己演到哪儿了，我只能，我只能，你什么也做不了。你只能走下台。所以你打算溜下台看一眼？
What are you going to do? I mean, you know, I don't know what else to do. Well, I tell you what's great now. I mean, because I'm a considerable old age now. Well, I don't really think about that, but other people tell me I am. No, no, no. You wear it well. You wear it well.
不然你能怎么办？我是说，你知道，我不知道还能做什么。嗯，我告诉你现在有什么好东西。我是说，因为我现在年纪很大了。嗯，我其实没怎么想过那个，但别人都说我老了。不，不，不。你状态保持得很好。你状态很好。
Yeah. Earpiece. I know. I know. But I don't know. I can't imagine somebody talking to you while you're talking. But only if you go up. Maybe if you, only if you go up, do they then talk?
是啊。耳机。我知道。我知道。但我不知道。我无法想象有人在你说话时还在跟你说话。但只有当你忘词时才会有？也许如果你，只有当你忘词时，他们才会说话？
So the earpiece, I've done the earpiece a few times. And the thing about the earpiece is don't think about it as learning lines. Think about it as volition in the play. That you want to keep it moving. So you want to keep it moving in a certain way. So this, because when you get to my age and you know, your brain isn't working in the same way, it's a little slower. So by the way, by the way, I saw your show in London, by the way. Oh, I didn't know that.
所以耳机，我用过几次耳机。关于耳机的一点是，不要把它想成是背台词。把它想成是戏里的意志。你想让它继续下去。所以你想以某种方式让它继续。所以这个，因为当你到了我这个年纪，你知道，你的大脑运作方式不一样了，稍微慢了一点。顺便说一句，顺便说一句，我在伦敦看过你的演出，顺便说一句。哦，我不知道。
Thank you. Yeah, I did. I just saw it. And you were absolutely brilliant. That was just an amazing show. But I do have a funny story about it, and please don't be offended by the funny story. But anyway, so I'm sitting there,
谢谢。是啊，我看了。我刚看完。你真是太棒了。那真是一场精彩的演出。但我确实有个关于它的有趣故事，请不要因为这个有趣的故事而感到冒犯。但总之，我坐在那儿，
and I'm watching this amazing evening. And I stood up and, you know, I kind of went, oh, Christ, because it was so extraordinary. Thank you. And the guy later on, the guy said, that was a wonderful mind. I said, what do you mean? I said, the guy, the way he mounted the piano.
看着这个美妙的夜晚。我站起来，你知道，我当时说，哦，天哪，因为它太非凡了。谢谢。后来那个人说，那真是个美妙的头脑。我说，你什么意思？我说，那个人，他弹钢琴的方式。
I said, that was him for real, you fucking idiot. You know, people have said that, And it's like, if I were to mime it or like, I'd have to imitate it perfectly with all the notes. So why not just play it? By the way, by the way, it would almost be more impressive if it was the mime. Right. That's almost harder than playing it. Was there ever that discussion, Sean, to turn the piano such that the audience,
我说，那是他真弹的，你这个蠢货。你知道，人们都这么说，就像，如果我要模仿它，或者说，我得完美地模仿所有的音符。那为什么不直接弹呢？顺便说一句，顺便说一句，如果是模仿的话，反而会更令人印象深刻。对。那比真弹还要难。肖恩，有没有讨论过把钢琴转个方向，让观众，
some of the audience could see the keys? Yeah, well, oh, I thought you'd say the other thing that they couldn't so that, because I did, I panicked before we opened, talking about a good night Oscar. Yeah. And talk before, I panicked. I was like, if something, if I hurt my hand or I can't do it or like, or I get scared and I've been playing it too many times, can we just run a tape and I'll just fake it with the keys facing a wave, you know?
部分观众能看到琴键？是啊，嗯，哦，我以为你会说另一件事，他们看不到，因为我，我在开演前恐慌了，说起《晚安，奥斯卡》。是啊。在谈话之前，我恐慌了。我在想，如果发生什么事，如果我伤了手，或者我做不到，或者我害怕了，而且我已经弹了太多次了，我们能不能放个录音，然后我假装弹，让琴键背对着观众，你知道吗？
Yeah. And the director's like, you're going to be fine. I'm like, but you don't understand. No, but you did record it though. You did have it recorded. Yeah, yeah, just in case. I never used it. Just in case, right?
是啊。导演说，你会没事的。我说，但你不明白。不，但你确实录了音。你确实录了。是啊，是啊，以防万一。我从没用过。以防万一，对吧？
But you never had to use it. No, I mean, I clearly your command was just dazzling. I mean, I said, I said, you know, what have I been doing for the last thing? I'll be fucking about. Well, Will and I went, Will and I were crying at the end of it. Jason and I were crying and we were crying. Oh, yeah, I was crying too.
但你从没用过。不，我是说，显然你的掌控力令人眼花缭乱。我是说，我说，你知道，我过去都在干什么？我都在瞎搞。嗯，威尔和我去了，威尔和我看完后都哭了。杰森和我都在哭，我们都在哭。哦，是啊，我也在哭。
I mean, A, and how beautiful was and how talented he was and B, how talentless we are compared to a few. Yes, I felt distinctly talentless after having watched it. Did you see Black Rabbit? Did you see Black Rabbit? No. That's okay. Pushing through.
我是说，A，他有多美，他有多有才华，B，比起他，我们是多么没才华。是的，看完之后我感到自己明显没什么才华。你看过《黑兔》吗？你看过《黑兔》吗？没有。没关系。继续努力。
Fantastic. Pretty fantastic. And, or is this thing on with Will or not and Lord? No. He'll get around to it all. So, wait, Brian, I wanted to talk to you. I wanted to get it before because this is one of my favorite films in film series, and I love the character of Ward Abbott
太棒了。相当棒。而且，或者这个节目是和威尔一起做的吗，还是什么？不。他会处理好一切的。所以，等等，布莱恩，我想和你聊聊。我想在之前就聊，因为这是我最喜欢的电影系列之一，我喜欢《谍影重重》系列里的沃德·阿博特这个角色。
from the Born movies. I don't know. I think people thought I was going to mention playing Hannibal Lecter, which, again, you are the original Hannibal Lecter in Manhunter, which I saw in the theaters. Great movie. In the 80s. I fucking loved that movie, and you were brilliant in that, really brilliant.
我不知道。我想人们以为我会提到扮演汉尼拔·莱克特，而你，又是《孽欲杀人夜》里最初的汉尼拔·莱克特，我在电影院看过。很棒的电影。在80年代。我他妈太喜欢那部电影了，你在里面表现得非常出色，真的很出色。
And I'm not just saying that But I'm such a born fan And I loved Ward Abbott And because there's a scene that you There's so many great scenes You're so great in those movies But there's a scene where the kid finds out That it's you that's you that's done it
我不是随口说说。但我真是个《谍影重重》的粉丝，我喜欢沃德·阿博特。因为有个场景，你……那里面有太多精彩的场景了。你在那些电影里太棒了。但有个场景，那个孩子发现，是你，是你干的，
And he takes you down and he says I figured it out And then what they did was they have a light switch And blah blah And the guy and you go Okay yeah you go okay Run it for me again And he does it again
他把你制服了，他说我查出来了。然后他们做的是，他们有个电灯开关，巴拉巴拉。那个人，你说了，好吧，是啊，你说好吧。再给我演示一遍。然后他又做了一遍。
And then you kill him In the most brutal way And it's one of my I remember the first The first time I watched it, I was like, oh, my, it was so shocking. So walk me through the BORN movies, if you can, just a little bit. Did you have a great experience? Was it a fun experience?
然后你杀了他，用最残忍的方式。这是我最……我记得第一次，第一次看的时候，我当时想，哦，天哪，太令人震惊了。所以，如果可以的话，带我回顾一下《谍影重重》系列，稍微回顾一下。你有过很棒的经历吗？那是一次有趣的经历吗？
Did you like that? Yeah, it was great. I mean, Doug Lyman is probably the most eccentric director you could have a meet. You know, he flies a plane like this. Right, yeah. He's extraordinary eccentric. But gifted, you know, just like he's got these flashes. Like, there's a, you know, I can't remember which film, I think it's the first one.
你喜欢吗？是啊，很棒。我是说，道格·里曼可能是你见过的最古怪的导演。你知道，他开飞机就像这样。对，是啊。他非常古怪。但很有天赋，你知道，就像他有这些灵光一现的时刻。比如，有个，你知道，我不记得是哪部电影了，我想是第一部。
There's a sequences where Jason Bourne falls, it's set in Paris, and he falls off, and it looks as if he's going to kill himself. But he falls onto another actor who goes down, and that breaks his fall. You remember that? Yeah, of course. That was Doug's idea.
有个序列是杰森·伯恩坠落，背景在巴黎，他掉下来，看起来他要自杀了。但他掉到了另一个演员身上，那个人倒下，缓冲了他的坠落。你记得吗？是啊，当然。那是道格的主意。
That was Doug said, why do we do that? That was the first one, in that stairwell, in that huge stairwell in the middle of the... Exactly, exactly. And it was amazing. I just couldn't believe it when I saw it. And I thought, my God, because it was very bright. brave of Matt to do it, but it worked like a dream, and it was wonderful.
那是道格说，我们为什么不那样做？那是第一部，在那个楼梯间，在那个巨大的楼梯间中间……完全正确，完全正确。太神奇了。我看到的时候简直不敢相信。我想，天哪，因为这非常勇敢，马特能这么做，但效果好极了，真是太棒了。
Yeah, there's such a great series of films. I just had to bring those up because I love them. So, so much. And of course, because I don't want to run out of time, and I know that people, because this is a big area, and people are going to, we'd be remiss if we didn't mention it, and so forgive us for, hopefully, bringing up succession, which has been so beloved around the world.
是啊，那真是一个伟大的电影系列。我只是不得不提一下，因为我太喜欢它们了。当然，因为我不想时间不够，而且我知道人们，因为这是一个很大的领域，人们会，如果我们不提它就太失职了，所以请原谅我们，希望提到《继承之战》，它在全世界都深受喜爱。
and talk a little, I mean, first of all, how did that come into your orbit, the success? I just got a call one day to say that Jesse Armstrong was thinking about this piece, and he would like to talk to me. So I got on a phone with Adam McKay, and who was one of the executive producers. Sure, yeah.
聊聊，我是说，首先，它是怎么进入你的轨道的，这个《继承之战》？我有一天接到个电话，说杰西·阿姆斯特朗正在考虑这个作品，他想和我谈谈。所以我跟亚当·麦凯通了电话，他是执行制片人之一。当然，是啊。
And, I mean, Jesse always wanted me to play the role. And I knew that I thought This is going to be a hit. I just knew it was really good. You know, it's so funny to hear you say that because we ask everybody, did you know it was going to be a hit? And people are like, you never know.
而且，我是说，杰西一直想让我演这个角色。我知道，我想，这会是个热门剧。我就是知道它真的很好。你知道，听到你这么说真有趣，因为我们问每个人，你知道它会成为热门剧吗？人们都说，你永远不知道。
But I love that you just said, I knew. I knew. I knew this was going to be one of the biggest shows of all time. Because the material was so strong? Yeah. And also, you know, just the part, I thought, wow, this is a great part
但我喜欢你刚才说的，我知道。我知道。我知道这会成为有史以来最伟大的剧集之一。因为剧本太强了？是啊。而且，你知道，就是这个角色，我想，哇，这是一个很棒的角色，
because it's so, it's a received part. You know, he's not, he just comes in at the right moment and then you've got this kind of real kind of intellectual kind of bandit that he is you know and it was just an extraordinary but the cast i mean the cast was amazing i mean and to watch all the actors grow through the whole show and uh and see the lovely serious snook you know uh roman you know i can never remember the names of the actors but they're also good. How did you like the
因为它是一个……这是一个很棒的角色。你知道，他不是，他只是在合适的时刻出现，然后你有了这种真正的，某种知识分子式的强盗，他就是这样，你知道，这真是太非凡了，但演员阵容，我是说演员阵容太棒了，我是说，看着所有的演员在整部剧中成长，呃，看到可爱的莎拉·斯努克，你知道，呃，罗曼，你知道，我永远记不住演员的名字，但他们都演得很好。你觉得那个
schedule of that? Was it, was it, did it seem just sort of relentless? Or was that, since it was an ensemble, the workload was all shared and no one ever really got gassed? No, no one really, it didn't become heavy in any way. And when it was a heavy episode, usually you weren't in it, you know, which is what was quite good, you know, like Kendall's birthday party. I wasn't in that episode at all.
时间表怎么样？是，是，它看起来只是那种无情的吗？还是因为它是群戏，工作量是分担的，没人真正累垮？不，没人真正，它在任何方面都没有变得沉重。当有一集很沉重时，通常你不在里面，你知道，这挺好的，你知道，比如肯德尔的生日派对。我根本没在那一集里。
And no, it was very, it was very. it was very relaxed and such great players like Matthew McFadion, you know, who's just a wonderful actor, you know. And all of them, they were all great, even Jeremy Strong. Yeah, sure, sure. And you were... Stop it now, Sean. Behave yourself.
而且不，它非常，它非常，它非常轻松，有像马修·麦克费登这样伟大的演员，你知道，他真是一个很棒的演员，你知道。他们所有人，他们都很棒，甚至杰里米·斯特朗。是啊，当然，当然。而你……别说了，肖恩。规矩点。
Please. I have a reputation, you know, I've got to think about it. Wait, so you find... So you get this material and you're like, okay, I think this is going to be hit. You like the party is a great part. It's a great, great part. and then you, what, you shoot the pilot, do you guys shoot a pilot, or do you go straight to series?
拜托。你知道我有声誉要考虑的。等等，所以你发现……所以你拿到这个剧本，你觉得，好吧，我觉得这会是个热门剧。你觉得这个角色是个很棒的角色。这是一个很棒，很棒的角色。然后你，什么，你拍了试播集，你们拍了试播集吗，还是直接拍了系列剧？
You know, that's a very good question. I can't remember. I think we went straight to, yeah. Adam McKay directed the pilot, yes? Yeah, yeah, he did. I think we went straight to series. Yeah. We did, I mean, no, I think we did the pilot,
你知道，这是一个很好的问题。我不记得了。我想我们直接去了，是啊。亚当·麦凯执导了试播集，对吧？是啊，是啊，他执导的。我想我们直接拍了系列剧。是啊。我们确实，我是说，不，我想我们拍了试播集，
and then it was literally like, I don't know, a month, and then we went on and did the series. But we kind of knew we were going to be doing the series. Right, right, right. I think so I may have got that wrong. Were you living in New York the whole time? Well, no, I was living in London to start with. And then I, yeah, I was, oh, I was cross-living.
然后真的就像，我不知道，一个月，然后我们就继续拍了系列剧。但我们当时就知道我们要拍系列剧了。对，对，对。我想是的，我可能记错了。你当时一直住在纽约吗？嗯，不，我一开始住在伦敦。然后我，是啊，我，哦，我两边住。
Yeah, because I live between London and New York. How do you like living in the States versus London? What's the pluses and the minuses? Oh, God. Where to start? Where to start? Be careful because we don't want you to get stopped at the border. No, no, no, no.
是啊，因为我住在伦敦和纽约之间。你觉得住在美国和伦敦相比怎么样？有什么优点和缺点？哦，天哪。从哪儿说起呢？从哪儿说起呢？小心点，因为我们不想让你在边境被拦下。不，不，不，不。
We live in funny times. I don't want any ice agents suddenly appearing on my hotel door. It's difficult. It's very difficult. I feel very sympathetic towards. Americans and where they're finding themselves at this time. Yeah. And in many ways it's a very exciting time, but it's also in many ways an acutely depressing
我们生活在有趣的时代。我可不想让任何移民局特工突然出现在我的酒店门口。这很难。非常难。我对美国人以及他们在这个时代所处的境地感到非常同情。是啊。在很多方面这是一个非常令人兴奋的时代，但在很多方面它也是一个极其令人沮丧的
time, you know. And I find that I go more to the depressing side than the exciting side. Yeah. And I just find it extraordinary because I love this. When I was a kid, you know, when I was 15, I, and I so wanted to be an actor. but I realized I wanted to be an American actor because I never wanted to be Kenneth Moore or Bougard or any of those English actors
时代，你知道。我发现我更多地倾向于沮丧的一面，而不是兴奋的一面。是啊。我只是觉得这太非凡了，因为我喜欢这个。当我还是个孩子的时候，你知道，当我15岁的时候，我，我非常想成为一名演员。但我意识到我想成为一名美国演员，因为我从来不想成为肯尼斯·摩尔或鲍嘉，或者任何那些英国演员，
and that just had nothing No connection Oh God, I'm saying You're being pernicious, Jason, absolutely pernicious And we will be right back And now back to the show I understand that too though Brian
那根本没有任何联系。哦，天哪，我在说什么。你太刻薄了，杰森，绝对刻薄。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。不过布莱恩，我也理解这一点。
As a Canadian, I also have the same And I'm very proud of being from Canada and I love it. But as a sort of a newer American of almost 20 years, I always wanted to come here too. I always had that thing like this was the place. It's such a great country, the
作为一个加拿大人，我也有同样的感觉。我为自己来自加拿大感到非常自豪，我爱它。但作为一个快20年的新美国人，我也一直想来这里。我一直有那种感觉，觉得这里就是那个地方。这是一个伟大的国家，
U.S. And there's so many incredible talents and there's so much opportunity to do so many different things. I think that was it. Do you know what I mean? And also the history of cinema. I mean, cinema's an American invention. You know, you can't deny it. Because my great passion is, in fact, my wife is
美国。这里有这么多不可思议的人才，有这么多机会去做这么多不同的事情。我想就是这样。你知道我的意思吗？还有电影的历史。我是说，电影是美国的发明。你知道，你无法否认。因为我最大的热情是，事实上，我妻子
so pissed off at me. Because I spend my days. I've been working really hard. I've done four plays. I played Bach. I've done a play about the financial crisis of 2008, which I played Adam Smith, you know, the history of... Do you know who Adam Smith was?
对我非常生气。因为我整天都在忙。我一直在努力工作。我演了四部戏。我演了巴赫。我演了一部关于2008年金融危机的戏，我在里面演亚当·斯密，你知道，历史……你知道亚当·斯密是谁吗？
No problem. Oh, yeah. Because he's a good education. Anyway, so... And I did that. I did that. And, no, it was great. But I...
没问题。哦，是啊。因为他受过良好的教育。总之，所以……我演了那个。我演了那个。而且，不，那很棒。但我……
And I realized that I wasn't... American. And it was very depressing when I realized what was I going to do? Well, I would say this. To us, you had a leg up being British, or Scottish, whatever. Yeah, no, yeah, it did. But just in terms of where you were going to go with your work, and it was just a very odd feeling. And then I was walking down the hilltown of my hometown, and there was a film on called Saturday night and Sunday morning. You probably haven't heard of that. Phil Mike. Sean's favorite.
我意识到我不是……美国人。当我意识到我该怎么办时，那非常令人沮丧。嗯，我会这么说。对我们来说，你是英国人或苏格兰人，无论什么，你都有优势。是啊，不，是啊，确实。但就你未来的工作方向而言，那是一种非常奇怪的感觉。然后我走在家乡的小镇上，有一部电影叫《周六晚上和周日早晨》。你可能没听说过。菲尔·迈克。肖恩的最爱。
It's a question last thing. It's Albert Finney. Love him. And when I saw Albert Finney, I thought I'm saved. If he can do it, I can do it. That guy from Salford, Manchester, I can do it, I can do it.
这是最后一个问题。是阿尔伯特·芬尼。爱死他了。当我看到阿尔伯特·芬尼时，我想我有救了。如果他能做到，我也能做到。那个来自索尔福德、曼彻斯特的家伙，我能做到，我能做到。
And also, Albert and I, subsequently, he was a bit older than me, but we worked together a couple of times, and I remember we did a play at the Royal Court, The Royal Court's a very famous theatre in London. Yes, yes. Oh, yeah, of course. Oh, God, sometimes it's really hard.
而且，阿尔伯特和我，后来，他比我大一点，但我们合作过几次，我记得我们在皇家宫廷剧院演过一部戏，皇家宫廷剧院是伦敦非常有名的剧院。是的，是的。哦，是啊，当然。哦，天哪，有时候真的很难。
Anyway. I look at these, you can't see, audience can't see it, I look at these bewildered faces, particularly the two on the bottom here. That's just their resting face. They have resting, bewildered face. But Alba Finney, he changed my life.
总之。我看着这些，你看不见，观众看不见，我看着这些困惑的脸，特别是下面这两个。这就是他们平时的表情。他们有平时的困惑脸。但阿尔伯特·芬尼，他改变了我的人生。
He just realized, I said, I can, I can, that's my path. And of course, it was the time of, which was an amazing time in the UK, of the beginning of what they called the free cinema. And it was Tony Richardson, Lindsay Anderson, who you didn't know, John Schlesinger, who you probably have heard of. Well, I put him in the same category as Lindsay Anderson, to be honest. But, Brian, you know, you have such an incredible,
他只是意识到，我说，我能，我能，那是我的路。当然，那是英国一个了不起的时代，被称为“自由电影”的开端。那是托尼·理查森，林赛·安德森，你可能不认识，约翰·施莱辛格，你可能听说过。嗯，老实说，我把他和林赛·安德森归为一类。但是，布莱恩，你知道，你有如此不可思议的，
you're very funny, you're very charismatic, you remind me of another Scottish, one of my closest friends, Patrick Doyle. Do you know this composer of Patrick Doyle? The composer. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. He composed Harry Potter and Cinderella. Yeah, he's a great friend of the Irishman, what you call. Jesus.
你非常风趣，非常有魅力，你让我想起了另一位苏格兰人，我最亲密的朋友之一，帕特里克·道尔。你认识这位作曲家帕特里克·道尔吗？那位作曲家。是啊，是啊。是啊，是啊，是啊。他为《哈利·波特》和《灰姑娘》作曲。是啊，他是那个爱尔兰人的好朋友，你叫什么来着。天哪。
Ken Brana. Oh, yeah, he does all Cambrana. You remind me of him a lot. I just didn't know if you knew each other. No, we've never met, actually, ironically. I've never met. You know what I want to ask you about? I want to ask you about, you know, Will and I moonlight a little bit with voiceover work sometimes.
肯·布拉纳。哦，是啊，他做所有肯·布拉纳的电影。你让我想起他很多。我只是不知道你们是否认识。不，讽刺的是，我们从未见过面。你知道我想问你什么吗？我想问你，你知道威尔和我有时会做点配音工作。
And I love the stuff that you do for McDonald's. McDonald's. I know. And I want to, how did, how did that come your way? Is that something that you, is that something that you enjoy? I mean, I love it. It gives you some very handy pocket change. He's loving it.
我喜欢你为麦当劳做的那套东西。麦当劳。我知道。我想，那是怎么找到你的？那是你喜欢的东西吗？我是说，我喜欢。它能给你一些非常方便的零花钱。他很喜欢。
It pays for a lot of stuff. It pays for a lot of stuff. I'm not complaining. Oh, yeah. How often do you find yourself in the booth recording new stuff? Well, it took a while, you know, because I've been here for, I mean, I've been here for nearly 30 years on and off, you know. Yeah. And I had a huge voiceover career back in the UK,
它能支付很多东西。它能支付很多东西。我没抱怨。哦，是啊。你多久会发现自己在录音棚里录新东西？嗯，花了一段时间，你知道，因为我在这里，我是说，我在这里断断续续快30年了，你知道。是啊。我在英国有过巨大的配音生涯，
which I couldn't keep up. And that was before they'd do things down the line, which they didn't do in the early days because it was too expensive. So I had a great voice career. And when I came here, it stopped. I lost my voice career. And then I had this agent guy called Steve Arcieri, who I would recommend to anybody.
但我无法维持。那是在他们做远程连线之前，因为早期他们不做那个，因为太贵了。所以我曾有过很棒的配音生涯。当我来到这里，它停止了。我失去了我的配音生涯。然后我有个经纪人叫史蒂夫·阿西里，我会向任何人推荐他。
He is a brilliant, brilliant agent. He's in New York. And he'd been watching up for me for a few years. and he just came at me at the right point and it was McDonald's and that was it. And then I did Uber Eats, you know, have you seen my Uber Eats commercial? I don't know.
他是一位非常、非常出色的经纪人。他在纽约。他为我观察了几年。他就在合适的时机找到了我，那是麦当劳，就是这样。然后我做了Uber Eats，你知道，你看过我的Uber Eats广告吗？我不知道。
I think I did. Oh, you've got to watch that. You've got to watch the Uber Eats. That's very funny. Is that on camera or is that voice open? Yeah, it's on camera. It's about, it's about a, it's about a sort of belligerent character who's going back to university
我想我看过。哦，你一定要看那个。你一定要看Uber Eats的广告。那非常有趣。那是出镜还是只配音？是啊，是出镜。它是关于，它是关于一个，它是关于一个有点好斗的角色，他回到大学，
in order to get Uber Eats because it's free. It's just price. Yeah, it's so good. is a series of vignettes. And it won an Emmy that whole so I've got that as well. I love ads. I love them.
为了得到Uber Eats，因为它是免费的。这只是价格。是啊，太好了。是一系列短片。它赢得了艾美奖，所以我也得到了那个。我喜欢广告。我喜欢它们。
Well, we do too, but I kind of want to sort of piggyback on what Jason was saying is because we do, as Jason said, we both have sort of moonlight sometimes and get to do these voice gigs. But you have such great command of your voice.
嗯，我们也喜欢，但我有点想顺着杰森刚才说的话说，因为我们确实，正如杰森所说，我们有时会做点副业，有机会做这些配音工作。但你对你的声音有如此好的掌控力。
That was Christian Linklater. Was it? There you go. That was Christian Linklater. That's when I found out that's why I went to Lambda. And then blow me, but six weeks after I got to Lambda, she left and came to America. She taught at Columbia for a long time.
那是克里斯汀·林克莱特。是吗？你看。那是克里斯汀·林克莱特。那就是我发现的，所以我去了兰达。然后，真倒霉，我到兰达六周后，她就离开了，去了美国。她在哥伦比亚大学教了很长时间书。
Oh, wow. But it's just, like even in something like the McDonald's ads, you understand such a way of bringing something to the voice in a way that is outside the norm. You know, with no disrespect to anybody else who does voiceovers, I've done it for a long time, and there's so many talented people out there. You mean like me?
哦，哇。但这就像，即使在像麦当劳广告这样的东西里，你理解那种将某种东西带入声音的方式，这超出了常规。你知道，对任何其他做配音的人没有不敬，我做了很长时间，外面有这么多有才华的人。你是说像我这样的人吗？
Because you've never said that to me. I'm just saying that Jason's never done that. I mean, Jason sounds like, talk about phoning it in. I mean... He does it on his phone. He does it on my phone. It's like leaving a voicemail message. And did they say do it in a higher octave?
因为你从来没对我这么说过。我只是说杰森从来没做过那个。我是说，杰森听起来，谈谈敷衍了事。我是说……他在手机上做。他在我的手机上做。就像留下语音留言一样。他们有没有说用更高的八度音阶做？
I don't understand. Buy a Hyundai. It's a great car. There it is. There it is. I just speak it, you know. But do you, and do you sense... I wonder also if you have that thing,
我不明白。买辆现代汽车。那是一辆好车。就是这样。就是这样。我只是说出来，你知道。但你，你感觉到……我也想知道你是否有那种东西，
which after years of doing voice servers where you understand, where you can look at a script. I have this thing where I can look at copy that they send me, and I'll go, and I'll go, see the timing, it'll go seven, seven seconds, and then I'll go like, yeah, I can probably do that in, I can probably do that in six and a half seconds. Yeah. Like, do you have that thing? Similar, similar thing.
在做了多年配音之后，你理解，你可以看剧本。我有这种东西，我可以看他们发给我的文案，我会说，我会说，看时间，它会是七秒，然后我会说，是啊，我可能能在六秒半内完成。是啊。就像，你有那种东西吗？类似，类似的东西。
I mean, usually the scripts are so good and so tight. That's the great thing with McDonald's. They've timed it out already, but. They've already timed it all, I have to worry. all I have to worry about is the performance, you know, just getting the, getting, well, can't you just like say if you did it took too long, if it took too long, you can't you just, wouldn't they just say, can you read it faster? Oh, yeah, yeah, they would tell me to hurry up, but I like to get out.
我是说，通常剧本都很好，很紧凑。这就是麦当劳的伟大之处。他们已经计时好了，但是。他们已经计时好了，我得担心。我唯一要担心的就是表演，你知道，只是得到，得到，嗯，难道你不能说如果它花了太长时间，如果它花了太长时间，难道他们不会说，你能读快点吗？哦，是啊，是啊，他们会叫我快点，但我喜欢快点结束。
We have a great expression in Scotland, which is get on and get off, which means get on and get off. And with voiceovers, I like to get on and get off and not hang about on them. Because that's the other thing, if you hang about too much, they don't, their density doesn't, it doesn't support you. And with voice of it is you have to drive them through, you have to do them, you know, and just be abandoned to them rather than sort of, because otherwise, you know,
我们在苏格兰有个很棒的表达，叫“上车下车”，意思是开始和结束。对于配音，我喜欢开始和结束，而不是在上面磨蹭。因为那是另一件事，如果你磨蹭太多，他们，他们的密度不会，它不支持你。对于配音，你必须驱动它们，你必须做它们，你知道，并对它们投入，而不是那种，因为否则，你知道，
you lose the job because you've only got an hour to do. I find myself getting kind of ordinary where I'll go, and I'll be doing something, and they'll say, you'll do a take and you'll go through and you'll get a perfect take, it's really good, you'll go, you'll lay it down and blah, blah, blah, and then they'll go, that's great. And they'll say, let's get one more for a safety, I go, safety, it's digital, right?
你丢了工作，因为你只有一个小时来做。我发现自己变得有点普通，我会去，我会做某事，他们会说，你会做一个录音，你会通过，你会得到一个完美的录音，它真的很好，你会去，你会把它放下来，巴拉巴拉，然后他们会说，那太棒了。他们会说，让我们再来一个作为备份，我说，备份，这是数字的，对吧？
What are you worried about a hair in the gate? What are you talking about? You got it. Now, if you want me to do it differently or you have a thought, great. But otherwise, we're good. Yeah, I couldn't agree with you more, Will. I mean, but again, we have director problems. Now, Brian, was it a gentle pitch that they made to you
你担心什么胶片卡住？你在说什么？你已经得到了。现在，如果你想让我换个方式做，或者你有想法，太好了。但否则，我们很好。是啊，我完全同意你的看法，威尔。我是说，但再次，我们有导演问题。现在，布莱恩，他们向你提出那个标志性的小叮当声时，是一个温和的提议吗？那个巴-达-达-巴-巴-巴-巴-巴。是啊。那是，但我总是，如果我不得不向布莱恩·考克斯提议，嘿，听着，我们想让你做这个。我会吓得要死，不敢让你做那个。还是那是你的主意？它在文案里吗？
when they asked you to do the iconic little jingle at the end there? The ba-da-da-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba. Yeah. Did that, but was that, I always, like, if I had to pitch Brian Cox, hey, listen, we'd like for you to do this. I'd be scared shitless to ask you to do that. Or was that your idea? Was it in the copy?
不，不，他们只是想让我做，我就做了。太好了。如果我了解杰森，杰森会说，你知道吗？那是不同的报酬率。是啊，那得唱歌。是啊，唱歌是不同的费率。肖恩，我说得对吗？J.B.会因为那个拖他们几周吗？
No, no, they just wanted me to do it and I did it. It's so good. If I know Jason, Jason would be like, you know what? That's a different pay rate. Yeah, that's going to be to sing it. Yeah, sing is a different rate. Sean, am I right? Would J.B. hold them up for weeks on that?
当然，是啊。我不知道。我会再给你打电话。我不会在你之后出现在你面前。不，但关于那个，我为那个发出“Aflac”声音的鸭子试镜，对吧？是啊，完美。没得到，哈？
Sure, yeah. I don't know. I'll call you back. I'm not going to show up to you up to you after. No, but what about, I auditioned for the voice of Affleck for that duck that goes, Affleck, right? Yeah, perfect. Didn't get it, huh?
那是在我和吉尔伯特·戈特弗里德之间，他得到了。我记得那次试镜，我走进去，我根本不知道它是为了什么。透过玻璃，你知道，我戴着耳机。他们只是读那里的文案，我当时想，Aflac？就像，我不明白。他们说，上面就写着这个。我说，上面就写着这个。就像，是啊，做就是了。
It was between me and Gilbert Godfrey, who got it. And I go, I remember the audition, and I go in there, and I had no idea what it was for. And through the glass, you know, I have my headphones on. And they were just read the copy there, and I'm like, Aflack? Like, I don't understand. And they're like, it's all it says. I'm like, that's all it says. Like, yeah, just do it.
然后我……像鹅一样做。像鹅一样。然后我说，Aflac。我不明白。我不明白你想要我……然后我说，太好了，谢谢。然后我说，嗯，我不知道
And I'm like... Do it like a goose. Like a goose. And I'm like, aflac. I don't understand. I don't understand what you want me to... And I'm like, great thanks. And I'm like, well, I didn't know
我应该听起来像个真正的动物。你觉得你的智力不足在其他方面阻碍了你吗？或者创造性冲动？是啊。哦，天哪。这些情况可能是暴虐的。但你去……
I was supposed to sound like an actual animal. Do you feel like your lack of intellect has held you back in other ways? Or creative impulse? Yeah. Oh, my God. It could be tyrannous, these situations. But you go to...
这是一个关于移动它的问题。你知道，我喜欢它。我喜欢它。我喜欢配音的纪律。你知道，这只是练习你手艺的一件伟大的事情，你知道。我同意。而且我喜欢它是一个狭小的空间。
It's a question of just moving it. You know, I love it. I love it. I love the discipline. I love the discipline of the voiceover. You know, and it's just a great thing to practice your craft, you know. I agree. And I like that it's a tight space.
我喜欢你只有有限的空间来表达这个观点。通常时间不多。而且关于那个，我发现了一些真的……GMC Sierra。你在谈论专业级吗？专业级GMCC。我们是专业的。但是，威尔，你被赋予了一个非常好的声音。
I like that you only have a finite amount of space in order to get this point across. Often it's not a lot of time. And there's something about that that I find really... GMC Sierra. Are you talking about professional grade? Professional grade GMCC. We are professional. But, Will, you're blessed with a very fine voice.
谢谢。我记得当我在那部精彩的电影里看到你时，那是你和布拉德一起拍的，我想，你的声音非常强。这是一个非常、非常好的声音。从你那里得到赞美，所以我很感激。非常感谢。你有很好的清晰度，
Thank you. I remember when I saw you in that wonderful film, which you did with Brad, and I thought, your voice is very strong. It's a very, very good voice. That's a compliment coming from you, so I appreciate it. Thank you very much. You've got great clarity,
那正是你扮演的那个角色如此美妙的原因，因为他在逃亡，但清晰度非常强，我印象非常深刻。如果他赢得了奖项，他要感谢的第一个人就是香烟。是啊。它们是唯一从未让我失望过的，谢尔德。
and that was what was so wonderful about that part you were playing, because he was on the run, but the clarity was so strong, and I was very, very impressed. If he ever wins an award, he's the first person he's going to thank is cigarettes. Yeah. They're the only ones who have never let me down, Sheld.
它们从未让我失望。它们从未不回电话。它们一直都在那里支持我。所以，布莱恩，你做过，这太有趣了，你回顾过去，你做过戏剧，你赢得了奥利弗奖，你赢得了英国电影学院奖、艾美奖和金球奖，所有这些，还有电影和电视。现在你执导了你的电影。
They've never let me down. They've never not returned to call. They've always been there for me. So, Brian, you've done, it's so funny, you go back, and you've done theater, you've won Olivier Awards, you won Bafters and Emmys and Golden Globes and all of it and film and television. Now you've directed your film.
这是其中之一，你知道，我们一直问人们，就像，你最想做的事情是什么？你似乎已经做到了，再次，冒着让你尴尬的风险。所以什么，什么让你早上起床，就像，现在你执导了这部电影，接下来让你兴奋得起床去做的事情是什么，某种创造性的？
It is one of these, You know, we ask people all the time, like, what is the thing that you'd like to do? You've seemingly done, again, at risk of embarrassing you at all. So what could, what gets you up in the morning of, like, now that you've directed this film, what's the next thing that kind of you're excited to get out of bed to do, sort of creative?
下一份工作。好的。下一份工作。你还有什么好奇想看看自己能否处理的事情吗？是啊。它只会在它来的时候来。你知道，我不能。你知道，你不能过度沉思。
The next job. Okay. The next job. Do you have anything left that you're curious to see if you can handle? Yeah. It only comes when it comes. You know, I can't. You know, you can't do over-contemplation.
我有什么，我有什么，我会怎么做，你知道，你只是去做。但就像你们在谈论独角戏，就像我几个月前确实拒绝了一个，因为我只是觉得那不是我能真正享受的事情。不，因为你不是一个人。你不是一个完整的人，这就是原因。就是这样。那是。
What have I, what do I, would I do how, you know, you just do it. But like you guys were talking about a one-man show, like I literally turned down one a couple of months ago because I just didn't think that's something that I could really enjoy doing. No, because you're not one man. You're not a full man, that's why. That's it. That's.
如果他们说半人秀。半人秀，你能做。你肯定能做半人秀。嗯，就像我得，我得在腰带下弄点戏剧，在我接受那样的东西之前。你应该，为什么不呢？不，不，我渴望做那个，但有些事情我是天才，杰森，我，我真的很想挑战自己，那是其中之一。我无法想象你的清单上还剩下很多挑战自己的事情。它在那里，我甚至不把它看作挑战，我只是把它看作工作，你知道，它是工作的一部分，它是工作的一部分，而且杰森，
If they said a half-man, if they said a half-man show. Half-man show, you could do. You could do a half-man. show for sure well like i gotta i gotta get some theater under my belt before i take something like that you should why don't you no no i'm dying to do that but like there are things that i am brilliant jason i would i would love to challenge myself that that's one of them i can't imagine there's a whole lot left on your list to challenge yourself with it's there it's i don't even see as a challenge i just see as the work you know it's part of the work it's part of the job and jason
你是一个非常好的演员，我是说，你知道，不，谢谢你。你是，我是说，你是，我是说，你做过《黑钱胜地》，你做过的工作。我觉得有时你对自己不够信任，杰森。哇。我觉得那是你的问题。我觉得那是你的问题。我觉得你真的，你非常克制。而且你克制的方式是，
you're a very fine actor i mean you know no thank you you are and i'm i mean you are and i mean you you've done the Ozarks, the work you've done. I think sometimes you don't trust yourself nearly enough, Jason. Wow. I think that's your problem. I think that's your problem. I think you really, you're very contained. And you're contained in a way it says,
如果我动得太快，我会摔倒。啊。看看这家伙。很棒的笔记。我觉得那是，你，只是让自己放手。你想看我放开它。你听起来像我妻子。是啊，她想让我。
if I move too fast, I'll fall over. Ah. Look at this guy. Great note. And I think that that's, you're, just let yourself go. You'd like to see me cut it loose. You'd sound like my wife. Yeah, she wants me to.
放开它。是啊，因为你不是。你太有天赋了。你太有才华了。你应该比现在更信任你的才华。他在这个节目《黑兔》里表现得非常好。天才。
Cut it loose. Yeah, because you're not. You're so gifted. You're so talented. And you should trust your talent more than you do. He did a very fine performance in this program, The Black Rabbit. Brilliant.
他很天才，天才，天才。而且他更……他是一个很棒的演员。他是一个很棒的演员。我曾有幸……抱歉，有幸与他多次合作。但我会说，杰森有……我总是对杰森这么说，
He's brilliant, brilliant, brilliant. And he is much more... He's a wonderful actor. He's a wonderful actor. I've had the misfortune... Sorry, fortune of working with him many times. But I will say, Jason has... And I always say this to Jason, too,
这是伟大的事情。他太风趣了。肖恩，你测试过了。最风趣的人。曾经。他的时机绝对无可挑剔，这是你无法教的。
and this is the great thing. He's so funny. Sean Yulintested. funniest person. Ever. His timing is absolutely impeccable that you cannot teach.
我一直对你说，杰森，我希望你回去做几部纯喜剧。你太他妈擅长喜剧了。嗯，如果它们还在制作，我在做吗？
And I say to you, Jason, all the time, I wish you to get back and do a couple straight comedies. You're so fucking good at comedy. Well, if they're still made, am I doing them?
但你在拒绝我们的喜剧。你为什么要拒绝我们？他们只是不再制作它们了。是啊，嗯，做一个节目。做他的八集喜剧节目。是啊。我很想。
But you're denying us of comedy. Why are you denying us? They just don't make them anymore. Yeah, well, make a show. Do his eight-episode comedy show. Yeah. I'd love to.
如果他们制作那些。他们制作。但你说你想做更多的戏剧，对吧？是啊，是啊，我很想做那个。而且我很想，我很想做更多的表演。我只是还没，我还没觉得，我不知道，这是一个关于，我喜欢扮演那些不那么有特色的角色的整个不同主题，为了缺乏更好的术语。
If they made those. They do. But you said that you wanted to do some more theater, is that right? Yeah, yeah, I'd love to do that. And I would love, and I would love to do some more sort of acting. I just haven't, I just haven't felt like, I don't know, it's a whole different subject about, I've enjoyed playing characters that aren't that charactery, for lack of a better term.
我有点厌倦了看演员演戏，所以我有点喜欢扮演直男和做更少事情的天才。但现在我开始思考。我可能想承担一些其他角色，并做更大、更广泛的表演尝试。我觉得你已经赢得了冒险的权利。是的。这不是冒险或信任天赋的问题。
I kind of got turned off to watching actors act, so I kind of like playing the straight man and the talent in doing less. But now I'm starting to think. I might want to take on some other characters and sort of do bigger, broader acting swings. I think you've earned the right to risk it. Yes. It's not a question of risk or trusting talent.
这只是不的问题。我被吸引的角色，如果我做了，如果我跑而不是走，我会演过头。杰森，我看不出你演过头任何东西。老实说。谢谢。因为你的品味，
It's just a question of not. The roles that I've been attracted to, I would be overplaying them if I did, if I ran instead of walked. Jason, I can't see you overplaying anything. To be honest with you. Thank you. Because your taste,
是精致的。嗯，你太客气了。哦，你们有那个。谢谢。这就是你们如此好的地方。所以比你现在更信任自己一点。也许我们应该进行一次私人会议。是啊，你知道。
is exquisite. Well, you are very kind. Oh, you guys have got that. Thank you. And that is what is so good about you. So trust yourself a bit more than you do. Maybe we should have a private session. Yeah, you know.
我会他妈的，我会付一大笔钱只是为了成为它的一点点并成为它的一部分。我很想和布莱恩和杰森开个会。哦，天哪，肖恩，那会有多有趣。我们已经完成了一半。我知道我们会弄清楚的。天哪，杰森，这就是你需要的。你需要一个导师。
I would fuck, I'd pay handsomely just to be a little bit of it and be a part of it. I'd love to have a session with Brian and Jason. Oh my God, Sean, how fun with that. We're kind of halfway there. I know we're going to figure it out. God, Jason, this is what you need. You need a mentor.
你甚至他妈的不知道。知道它。是啊。布莱恩，你，你用你的才华指导了我们所有人这么多年。我们非常感谢你来到这里。我们非常，我们祝你继续成功，在格伦·罗斯和你执导的电影中取得巨大成功。恭喜。
You didn't even fucking know. know it. Yeah. Brian, you have, you've mentored us all with your talent for so many years. We are so grateful for you coming on here. We're so, we wish you just continued success and a lot of success with Glenn Roth in your film that you've directed. Congratulations.
我迫不及待想看到它。布莱恩·考克斯，你绝对是一个传奇，一个偶像，谢谢你今天成为我们节目的一部分。嗯，这绝对是，我是说，这是一种荣幸，老实说，能和你们三个如此不可思议和有才华的家伙交谈。这是一种荣幸。这是一种荣幸。所以谢谢你，亲爱的。就是这样。谢谢你，布莱恩。谢谢你，布莱恩。谢谢你，布莱恩。谢谢你，伙计。谢谢，布莱恩。谢谢你，布莱恩。伟大的布莱恩·考克斯。再见，伙计。太棒了。祝你有美好的一天。保重。再见。再见。再见。
I can't wait to see it. Brian Cox, you are an absolute legend in Icon and thank you for being part of our show today. Well, this was an absolute, I mean, this is an honor, to be honest, to talk to you three guys of such incredible and talent. It's an honor. It's been an honor. So thank you, darling. There we go. Thank you, Brian. Thank you, Brian. Thank you, Brian. Thank you, buddy. Thanks, Brian. Thank you, Brian. The great Brian Cox. See you, bye, pal. Amazing. Have a good day. Take care. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
我迫不及待想看了。布莱恩·考克斯，你是偶像界的传奇，感谢你今天参加我们的节目。说实话，能和你们三位如此出色且有才华的人交谈，我感到非常荣幸。这是一种荣幸。这真的是一种荣幸。所以谢谢你，亲爱的。好了。谢谢你，布莱恩。谢谢你，布莱恩。谢谢你，布莱恩。谢谢你，伙计。谢谢，布莱恩。谢谢你，布莱恩。伟大的布莱恩·考克斯。再见，伙计。太棒了。祝你今天过得愉快。保重。再见。再见。再见。
Bye-bye. Wait, you know what? First of all, he's an absolute delight. Like, I had no idea. He was so funny and, like, breezy, you know, like light and breezy. I had the opportunity. I said this to Brian. He came to a, uh, uh, he came to a, uh, a screening of our film a few months ago, and I got to talk to him afterwards, and he went out, like 30 years ago, he was friends with somebody I knew, and I was out here as one of my first times in California,
再见。等等，你知道吗？首先，他绝对是个让人愉快的人。我完全没想到。他非常风趣，而且，怎么说呢，很轻松，你知道，就是那种轻快随和的感觉。我有过一次机会。我跟布莱恩说过这件事。几个月前他来参加我们电影的放映会，之后我有机会和他交谈。他提到大约30年前，他和我的一个熟人是朋友，而那是我第一次来加州，
and he said, we're going to go by Brian Cox's renting house in the Hollywood Hills, and we're going to go watch the Oscars. At his house? At his house? Okay. That he was renting. So I went up, it was like one of my first time ever,
他说，我们要去布莱恩·考克斯在好莱坞山租的房子，我们要去那里看奥斯卡颁奖典礼。在他家？在他家？好吧。那是他当时租的房子。所以我去了，那是我第一次经历那种事，
like, doing that thing, you know, you've come from not here, and you go up into the Hollywood Hills, to a house and you're like, oh my God, look at the lights and everything. And then you go in and here's this guy who's this working actor, acclaimed working actor, and going to his house, and I was about, you know, 25, and going into his house and just being, and he was, you know, just sort of blown away,
你知道，从外地来到这里，走进好莱坞山的房子，你会想，天哪，看看这些灯光和一切。然后你走进去，这里有这个家伙，一个职业演员，备受赞誉的职业演员，我当时大概25岁，走进他的房子，感到非常震撼，
not knowing what to say and, you know, and all you want to do is get a job. And he was so kind and so gracious. I was just some stupid-ass kid. I'm not much different now, but he was, I'm some stupid-ass kid. And he was so welcoming and generous and made me feel. And I was like, what a fucking great dude.
不知道该说什么，你知道，你唯一想做的就是找份工作。但他非常友善、非常亲切。我当时只是个蠢小子。现在也没好到哪去，但我当时就是个蠢小子。他非常热情慷慨，让我感觉很好。我当时就想，这真是个了不起的家伙。
Yeah, you can tell. Yeah. Why don't you, you should have told him that story? Because I didn't want to cry. Oh, Will. Yeah. Okay. Or have him say, no recollection.
是啊，看得出来。是啊。你为什么不告诉他那个故事呢？因为我不想哭。噢，威尔。是啊。好吧。或者让他说，完全没印象。
Yeah, I don't. Turn the tables on us. Did I? No, it doesn't sound like me. Doesn't sound like me. Willie, you need to do, what about you doing theater too? I think Jason would be fucking brilliant. to play, and so with you.
是啊，我没印象。反过来问我们。我有吗？不，那听起来不像我。不像我。威利，你需要做，你演戏怎么样？我觉得杰森会非常出色。去演戏，你也是。
I don't know if I have the character for it. Or the voice. Or the voice. You've got to reach the back row with your pipes. Yeah, you got to reach the Italian guy in the back. You know, you always want you're like, oh, whatever you do, do not take the Lessington bus and then go across out and then cross back, like a Neil Simon play, you know what I mean? Well, he was delightful.
我不知道我是否有那个性格。或者嗓音。或者嗓音。你得用你的嗓门传到最后一排。是啊，你得传到后面那个意大利人那里。你知道，你总是想，噢，无论你做什么，千万别坐莱辛顿巴士，然后穿过去再穿回来，就像尼尔·西蒙的剧一样，你明白我的意思吗？嗯，他很讨人喜欢。
I love that guy. He is a delight. He really, really was. What a great, great actor. What a great career. My God. And it doesn't sound like he's going to slow down at all. No.
我喜欢那个家伙。他真是个让人愉快的人。他真的，真的非常棒。多么伟大、伟大的演员。多么伟大的职业生涯。天哪。而且听起来他一点也没有要放慢脚步的意思。没有。
Waiting for the next gig. Yeah. And I love that he's doing like radio plays and it's just, ah, God, he just does. Kind of does it all. The good way, Sean is just making us hang here, making us come up with a buy. You know, Sean is coming. I got one. I got one that may or may not have just popped up.
等着下一份工作。是啊。而且我喜欢他做广播剧之类的，天哪，他真的什么都做。以一种好的方式，肖恩只是让我们在这里耗着，让我们想出一个再见。你知道，肖恩来了。我有一个。我有一个可能刚刚想到的。
Oh. Yeah. Oh, you know, wait, Sean, I have one. Wait, no, sorry, I have one. Oh, okay. What's yours? What's yours? Well, you know, it was great.
噢。是啊。噢，你知道，等等，肖恩，我有一个。等等，不，抱歉，我有一个。噢，好吧。你的是什么？你的是什么？嗯，你知道，这很棒。
And what a great simple name to remember. You know, if you can't remember his name, you could always recall. Oh, yeah. What's his name? What's his name? Bye in Cox. Bye. Wait, I don't get that.
而且这是一个多么简单好记的名字。你知道，如果你记不住他的名字，你总能想起。噢，是啊。他叫什么名字？他叫什么名字？Bye in Cox（再见考克斯）。等等，我不明白那个梗。
I still don't get it. Because Bennett said it to all of us and it said, buy in Cox. It says Bayern Cox. I still don't get it. What is it? Instead of Brian, Bayern, Bayern. Oh. So dumb.
我还是不明白。因为贝内特对我们所有人说了，他说，Buy in Cox（买入考克斯）。他说的是Bayern Cox。我还是不明白。是什么意思？代替Brian，Bayern，Bayern。噢。太蠢了。
His music. Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav, and Bennett Barbico. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他的音乐。Smartless。Smartless是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗伯·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴比科100%有机且手工制作的。Smartless。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。